at the Second World Conference of peace
and light in the Dominican Republic
Rosser received the Tuttle world
ambassador of peace and life by the
foundation 1a1
and its president dr. angel dr. angel
that's his name there's not dr. ankle
right yeah it depends on the hospital
and hell it says angel and I mean it
makes it so what's this title again
world ambassador to peace and light and
light specifically life so what you're
looking at here is a show real of all
the light I don't know what the [ __ ]
this guy but like all the lives he's
touched and all the miracles he's
performed there yet oh nice look at that
game man I'm cured already they just
tease you because you have to pay for it
of course
yeah yeah he doesn't give you the gaze
we don't give that [ __ ] away for free
come on I'll look at him admiring all
these the nations he's traveled in heal
he's such a dollar store Fabio
oh absolutely right it's like oh we
couldn't quite get the real guy so he
just looks really he's a he's got a
strong gaze and usually people cry look
at them whole damn city he's got a
dreamy thing going you know like the
character true P the dog just kind of
mmm
hey but apparently it's miraculous so
good for him street fights just ending
throughout that entire absolutely hey
how you doing guys welcome welcome to
our show here my favorite guests we have
Jack's films and Eric from comment
etiquette internet coma etiquettes
actual precise name two of my favorite
guests here together can I ask for
anything better that I've avoided my
heart that had to be filled by some
Hennessy some cigarettes and some
sparkling rose a this so thank you guys
and thank you guys for coming here and
joining us on this glorious Friday
good job making it through the week to
you guys and them as well yeah here's to
the weekend and we're just here to have
a laugh have have a couple of gifts a
couple of bills yeah yeah you know booth
is oh yeah oh mama bleep oof in this
later on
I have questions so let's cheers to
building and we'll tell everybody about
the bill
Seuss said to booths you're gonna love
this specifically you Jack oh I'm
excited already so you guys know about
like the goofs and spoofs in the gaps
naturally it's your specialty so I saw
this on the line I saw this word booth I
was like what the [ __ ] there's like a
whole new so a whole new like piece of
the puzzle I don't even know existed a
booth B oo f exact okay swing chart it's
so I'm like okay what's this mean and I
look it up it's not actually word but
you found it on urban dictionary hell
yeah the best which is the perfect place
to define something like this apparently
and correct me if your definition is
wrong it's when you shove drugs up your
ass when you go to a rave or dance party
you booth it in yes we're on the same
page that's accurate how did you know
that independently of this yeah these
things up through life you know yeah
been around the ball when you we move
the gobble mile in my shoes you know the
booth is just the beginning of the road
right mr. booths they call me mr. booths
they call me mr. booth well we've got a
couple of gifts and that bill I'll be
boof and all kinds of [ __ ] later for
charity that's great tune in that's
great so that's my new favorite thing as
a booth it's a bit of a booth yeah this
whole episode is gonna be a bit of a
build before we get too deep I want to
thank our sponsors quit stitch fix and
wink with a see more about that later
and I also want to give a shout out to
ela who isn't here by the way - yeah
Cheers this I don't know if should we
spill it out like well yeah we need like
a patch of dirt or something they're
forgetting his actor he's gonna but
she's not dead no way to catch it [ __ ]
the table up oh you just drink it you
know I spilled a little bit earlier so
count it yeah I'll look at that that's
for your lucky Allah poured a little bit
the shot glass she had to go home for
some family stuff
oh right for two weeks 10 weeks it's
kind of it's a rough oh man her dad was
diagnosed with lung cancer ah man looks
like stage 3 ah sorry so and you know
it's [ __ ] happens you know she's there
spending time with her family and I'm
here
[ __ ] trying to booth yeah well no
wait make sure you use with your famine
we're your family
okay I love you guys today love you man
I need you guys have more than ever
Cheers
so speaking of Elah and have a booth
there for you
mmm yeah we were prepared we've got like
too much liquor out so much stuff going
on you know I want to talk to me a
labott I seen these cigarettes here and
I'm like before the show I don't know
what's wrong with me hmm
every time we start this show I have to
[ __ ] it's a trigger it's it's a like a
like a natural like when you go to the
movie theaters I always crave a cherry
coke okay and it's one of those like you
know you have to fight it's the same
thing same yeah is perfect yeah
absolutely so it's it's one of there are
other examples too I'll think about it
40 minutes into the podcast yeah I'm
talking about something completely
different
Oh another one and you guys will be like
Jack shut the [ __ ] up but yeah it's just
it's a natural biological thing where
it's like you have to do it you have
that though where it's like not not
about cherry coke since up but
specifically about [ __ ] mmm because
it's so I don't know what's with the
body and poop like I'll poop in the
morning every time cuz I'm like I cannot
go through this again and I'm like we're
gonna be smoking we're gonna be drinking
if I don't [ __ ] now I'm gonna [ __ ] my
pants yeah you don't want to [ __ ] your
pants during the show yeah I mean what
if that did happen no like what we do it
obviously [ __ ] yourself they wouldn't
know at home but me and Jack would know
your viewers weird looks maybe back and
forth oh no we could continue that I
don't know if we hear we get out yeah I
don't think you guys could just be
classy about that yeah and I'm gonna
want you to I would I would me and Jack
would be like texting each other and
we're I look rude like we were like not
just me well I would blame it on Eric
people would buy that yeah I have [ __ ]
myself right now
right now currently [ __ ] wait actually I
know do you have like poop triggers yeah
well I mean it's the same as what you're
just describing I think whenever you're
about to get out of the house and do
something you know yeah your body's like
well what one second yeah we we huddle
up real quick
right talk about what we need to do well
[ __ ] a so obnoxious because it's
like with pissing you feel it coming you
know that you got to do some [ __ ] it's a
rare bit and it's done right
but shitty can creep up on you anytime
and then you're incapacitated for X
number of minutes yeah I hate it I
absolutely hate it I'm still reeling
from that one well anyway we were a
little late to the start on Twitch so if
you guys [ __ ] just I was sitting here I
was ready I was feeling confident and I
was like I'll be back in ten minutes and
they were coming in I was going out you
know there's nothing like sitting on a
public toilet you know and [ __ ] your
brains out knowing that there's
thousands of people waiting for you yeah
so if I'm ever late that's what happened
he's [ __ ] yeah when you're when
you're [ __ ] in public do you stop
[ __ ] if somebody walks into the
bathroom yes generally I I like that I
do the same thing I always wonder what
it is about people that they just like
[ __ ] don't care like they just keep
going if I walk into a public bathroom
someone's taking a [ __ ] I envy those
people I expel my god you know you're so
empowered yeah I'm sure a lot of urinal
like always have severe stage yeah if
somebody walks in next to me for the
most part I'll just uh it's so bad I'll
sit there and pretend like yeah yeah
I've contemplated and I'm taking my time
right you gotta close your eyes yeah
Waterfalls and then what happens when
you have too shy peers
next to each other like a [ __ ]
standoff that's what you call eternity
that's nice that's like a four for
blondes at a four-way intersection where
I stopped right I always wait them out I
always win that game of chicken well
think it's real i beer all day buddy you
gotta finish all right right cuz you're
not hearing anything out it's a standoff
it's humiliating yeah of Cour no it's
one of the worst feelings in the world
but what you do if they take too long
you just slowly turn to them right and
you go just with it out yeah yeah and
you just stare and I'm like I like that
it's a game of can you dominate you get
your alphabet ooh you can't but you get
your alphabet right and not just and
that's what matters yeah who cares if
you didn't empty
bladder I bite them on the neck right in
the name oh that's so they know that I'm
deaf oh that's a little further than I
want to carry them out of the bathroom
what do you want to be the Alpha or not
I guess there's no there's that levels
of alpha didn't realize yeah step it up
man yeah do you ever do this where
you'll go to the bathroom and it's just
way too awkward that you'll actually be
standing at the stall and you'll
completely leave the bathroom without
paying yeah that is the [ __ ] I don't
know I definitely I've cooked that low
for sure mm-hmm
I did my business I just walk out all
stiff-legged it that sucks yeah go in
stare yourself in the mirror for twenty
seconds and I just leave yeah people who
talk while [ __ ] like I've told the
story in the podcast before but just to
give you guys the Reader's Digest cuz it
happened to me in this office mmm I've
was absolutely fascinated by it
fascinating I can't say fascinating
anymore that's awesome there's one
button it's just fascinating fascinating
those are nice open to you know yeah I
was like Dan and you nailed it okay so
yeah this is what happened here I go in
I'll give you a straw one cuz a lot of
people probably heard this I go in I'm
sitting at the stall they don't know I'm
in there they come in they're talking
dude one dudes at the urinal one dudes
in the [ __ ] they're talking the whole
time though dude is blasting ass at
10:10 volume how can you maintain a
conversation doesn't miss a beat they
finish at the same time their boyfriends
they fought they were talking about I
thought yeah they finish at the same
time dude doesn't wash his hands they
leave together
and they're all good and they moved on
with their life dozen washes 1 peed 1
polluted for the same rate and left
together my best friend in the world I
wouldn't do that with him I don't like
that's that's a level of friendship that
that surpasses anything I know that's
like army [ __ ] yeah yeah that is army
[ __ ] yeah they were in the [ __ ] yes when
were they old yeah they were they were
middle-aged they weren't from that
generation always that that's why that's
like asthma millenials but you know like
we wouldn't do that I can see I think
when we're that age we might yeah I
think when we get into shifty
when you get old we're gonna be that guy
talking on the phone while [ __ ]
that's for sure for sure but there these
are the guys who you go into the gym and
they're the dudes who are just there
naked all yeah yeah and they'll just
look at you see that I don't I don't get
that I don't get that at all I down 70
years old I'll never do that well I hope
not but I mean you know what I mean
though I don't get you well it's a
generation thing these kids used to
shower together at the gym naked true
true true and they'd have the gym
teacher so they like anything yeah right
we don't do that no it's [ __ ] weird
Stahl's back then what's that I didn't
have doors on stuff all right
really just like right I mean back then
they would make you it was like this
whole masculinity thing they'd be like
you have to get naked and shower with
your friends or you get an F it's not
real
dan looked that up Ian look that up
somebody look that I'm sorry no you're
right it's real that's real I want to
believe I want what I want to hurt yeah
they were our second Hummer Audrey thing
you know you know just to tighten the
bond of brotherhood right nuclear war
was right around the corner yeah like
here's my dick yet for some reason
bathing suits were so much bigger mmm
you know world you see what I see that's
we call the inverse relationship if you
ask me so anyway what the [ __ ] the
point of this where are we we were
taught oh yeah I was talking about Teddy
fresh so I just want to say give a quick
announcement here that Teddy fresh ILA's
clothing line is getting close guys yeah
a fresh official this is just a basic
shirt the crazy [ __ ] she's working on
she hasn't really shown yet but I think
by the end of this month early next
month we are going to be jamming that's
awesome
this is Teddy fresh official on
Instagram I'm super excited send your
love and wonderful thoughts to they he
looks loner dubbed by you Eric gillich
loner
hmm oh did I I think so yeah I'll take
it
well join your clone segment and maybe
it was the twitch it might have been an
offset of that I don't think I'm that
clever
if I buy Teddy Teddy fresh you would
have to buy it we'll send you everything
both you guys well you can you hand
deliver it to me at my address
cool cool thanks guys
I'll Doc's the hell out of you buddy
do absolutely it's an absolute guarantee
and just another announcement before we
get too deep into this oh look at this
the raffle and charity giveaway is still
live we're gonna wrap it up we decided
next are this coming Tuesday brought two
hundred thirty three thousand guys
listen to this okay goddamn [ __ ]
listen if the we get to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars me Justin and
Alex are gonna smut are gonna rap
Skippy's bellybutton lint and pubes into
a blunt and smoke it oh that was
Justin's idea this weekend we need 250
we will make an h3 video of a smoking a
blunt of Skippy's belly look oh it's
yeah Justin's like I'm not gonna inhale
at those look on the [ __ ] alright have
you seen that [ __ ] um you want to smell
it it's here Ian can you bring in the
lint please oh my god so guys get on
those donations Jesus Howard Stern ain't
got [ __ ] on this package no package that
if I remember correctly his reason for
doing this was that what the [ __ ] was
his reason for it was some kind of part
of his missionary work okay so they lost
something he had to do a daily ritual or
something and so I'm gonna throw up if I
smell this by the way this didn't get a
lot of bids I was yes I will hit lightly
past I I will I'll just you know believe
you guys how much if somebody donates it
for you to smell sad again somebody
donates how much what's that threshold
that you'll significant that 25 bucks if
someone donates oh god if someone donate
you can be as high as you want yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna have to but if someone
donates like $5,000 [ __ ] off notch notch
are you watching my grant because oh
come on that's rancid how about a
thousand one thousand short short one
thousand you're here for 25 25 Hey
hey you want wait wait $25 not tithing
500 just 25 I was just about to do it
for free
I'm going I'll do it with you yeah at
least look at it yeah yeah look look I
want to know what I'm gonna say looking
at it right now right we bit we raffled
off all these griten they have to take a
close look it's like the most it's like
a nug of weed it's looks and instead of
dank like you know how there's like red
tendrils its pubic hair
I swear and you guys are trying to sell
this well skip evaluated at $2,500 and
whose eye I missed the start of this
whose is this hippy the verge the 34
year old virgin okay you know yeah I
can't believe there's not like any
witches out there who need this for like
a spell you don't know that Lee button
lint of a virgin man it's true but I
still have it so they're not betting on
it which is but we also found Seoul
needs to know about this we all signed
it so it's still available if you guys
want to yeah I like that it's in a
Christmas I'd like to buy it but can you
dump the lint out and send me the signed
container I'll let you Oh God just just
cast your eyes on that but doesn't it
look like a nuggie like a bizarro nugget
smells like one okay your nose in there
oh my god does it smell like anything
okay your your chance it smells like
pieces of clothing that became lying
someone mine bellybutton yeah thousand
dollars somebody owes us now put your
get your nose in it man
that's great no it's great yeah that's
actually not not as bad as I really hate
it really I feel nauseous just it's more
of like cubes and stuff oh yeah I see
you know it's it's when you describe it
yeah that's when I start kidding yeah
the idea that smells better yeah it's
worse the worse that's when you actually
stick your nose oh you guys you're yeah
just don't think about and I get can you
get some how smells a lot better than my
belly button lint
oh it does it yeah how's your collection
looking these days oh I got it I got
like a like a rupture so of God it's a
bit of a smell yeah it's got such a
stink
oh this is available for for buying this
is available for purchase
sign me up man it's available here on so
guys I
really counting on you 250,000 come on
you're so close you are so close that is
17 not even 17 grand away alright that's
pops gonna hit it for [ __ ] until Tuesday
this Tuesday well I want to shoot it
this weekend okay are you gonna put
actual weed in the blunt or absolutely
honest I need a purely not appear I know
that's where you draw the line you know
that's illegal
[Laughter]
all right so anyway I'll check back in
on those donations that is horrific
mm-hmm so it's so weird you know there
you go the thing was like I need to [ __ ]
so that I can smoke mm-hmm cuz I don't
know you you never smoked not read I may
have dabbled in like one or two
cigarettes in my life but it's not real
I'm a drinker doing the same room a
combination for my lack of smoking why
do both you that's fine too
I literally for everyone who's crying at
home
Oh Ethan's gonna die oh I love those got
some I had a cigarette was with this guy
so if anyone's gonna die attempt I'm
fine no I'm cool record [ __ ]
remember kids smoking kills all right
we'll just clone me well talk to it
there are healthier ways to live boys
were all girls drool this is a sausage
party yeah this is the boys club edition
the drunkest podcast yet and we're only
about 20 minutes in absolutely this is
our own version of high gets Doug or
what's it what's that one called yeah I
always think that name well it's written
like confused getting Doug with high
thank you that's exactly yep this is
show this is getting boofed
getting Ethan with boof I'm using an
e-cigarette this entire time
take it puffs as we speak yeah I keep
moving the chair up and down to activate
it love that name is Ian Rush a tight
tight shot of Eric goofing anyway I
heard over here yeah by myself mm-hmm
it's the first time I've ever heard by
myself no [ __ ] very first time it was
very weird I do it all the time how'd
you like it did you like it well it was
weird yeah cousin yeah dude you like try
to make conversation with the driver
yeah I'd meet yeah I don't want to hear
anything from them yeah anything ever I
mean right one of my worst
sorry I just real quick one of my worst
ever experiences was when I oh you know
the uber driver shows up I opened the
back door to get in the Oberer the
driver says oh no no come come sit up
consider the passenger seat whoa
so that's how I knew I was in for a ride
you'd be like oh I'm fine back here
yeah I didn't you see I should have said
that I'm too like passive no I wouldn't
I don't say that either I think our scam
cloth yeah yeah yeah I think we are too
or so it's do like yeah we're shy peers
and we both like when it when a uper
driver tells us to sit up in the
passenger seat we do it so I did and you
just [ __ ] talk to my and it was like
a Ford it wasn't a short ride it was
like from downtown LA to North Hollywood
and it was like a 40-minute drive and
this guy just talked and talked about
God knows what I'll never remember but
he was a very he was a chip it was like
10:00 at night or 11:00 and everyone's
tired I'm tired and he just no he wanted
our conversation so I totally get it
like the whole hey man just just do your
job I don't really want to have a
conversation you can never say that
though it's the rudest thing ever oh of
course no idea number one well you're in
the front you could always just reach
and turn the volume of the radio drown
him out that's the equivalent of like
putting up the the screen yeah you know
like I see in movies oh it's not rude
no yeah in a limo it's expected so you
get that snob eNOS comes with the right
hey I'm gonna I'm gonna jack off back
here yeah don't look okay
don't that's one way to shut him up so
you're not used to that riding alone
well actually he was quiet he was
respectful here's the thing that I don't
get about Guber Trevor's that that talk
to you because they usually come at you
with like a set of stories yeah and it's
like do you tell the same start like
you'll get in a car and they'll tell you
their life story to tell you about the
way that he's got a deforest and we're
good for work it's like do you tell this
to everybody in here because I'm not
receptive right yeah that makes it yeah
I'm not inquiring I'm not digging for
more no no they just give you this
straight yeah you know you're just
trying to get to a Ralph's and then they
start giving his life story right is it
a scam like listen if you want therapy
this you're gonna have to pay for this
every customer they pick
maybe they what if they're all actors
and this is their like this is their
rehearsal this is their script and
they're just trying to like perfect
their life store they change it every
time they change up their story every
time
yeah that's not what's happening no not
at all I'm reading way too deep in it
but it's nice to dream because because
the reality is too sad you're out the
reality of it is really sad I'm on the
other side I asked them like to me how's
your marriage so you do I see you have a
pale spot on your finger where a wedding
ring used to be terrible
care to divulge sir how is your level of
observation right right right
don't mind the scratches on your
steering wheel that they're only driven
by a woman
did you win some sort of settlement
there I wonder if there's like uber
drivers probably shoot the [ __ ] about
bad passengers who's who do that they
have two annual uber convention VidCon
for uber drivers right absolutely it's a
hoot yeah the like the stuff I like to
hear is uh like celebrity passengers I
got a bunch of friends who yeah drove
for lyft and uber just to like after
work yeah way to go make a buck yeah
yeah and they make some peer money and
[ __ ] I know wow I got friends who do
that too yeah somebody got Courtney Love
in there in the Wow and she didn't like
the song that was playing on the radio
was it her song it wasn't it wasn't her
song I don't think he recognized her
until like after but I forget what the
[ __ ] song was so to be subscribe for
the best cuz I don't wanna have Courtney
Love looking at me up and be like I
never did that yeah I mean like her
voice is so scratchy I don't think I
would recognize her if I bumped and turn
the street can you change the music
sorry come again I'm gonna roll up the
window don't look I'm masturbating cuz
they bring back dividers please I feel
like that's such a bygone era can we
have them in regular cars yeah I think
like Tesla oh we need one between the
passenger they shotgun Elon waiting for
the divider Elon ice give you a lot of
flattery on the show can we please get a
divider between the shotgun and the
driver you can oh it's listen.you I'll
be like listen Eric I'm a jerk-off don't
look
clear one way it's just not just the
window there's holes in it you can hear
me I've got like a dry erase marker and
just like your own stuff you don't work
the [ __ ] are you come on you on uh so
what else is going on with you guys
how's everything you were in uh you were
on vacation reason was yeah so we just
had a nice little nine-day vacation in
Ireland and then London and it was
awesome it was just I I just want to say
it's so much better over there than it
is here we should all move we shall just
pack up our things and just move to the
UK and they'll be building the wall I
mean I don't blame him it's just I you
know but uh so okay long story short
just a lot of beer beer Guinness and
beer and it was a lot of fun but the
highlight and we peaked early you know
this is like on night 2 of 9 of our
vacation right but we were in some tiny
little local bar in Donegal Ireland
you know this quaint adorable awesome
town in Ireland and then these fans come
up in the bar and there are these young
kids they're like 18 19 years old you
know but and it's like their last yeah
so they they come in it saw like a lot
of that you know we're buying shots and
rounds and stuff and then the night goes
from great to incredible when they're
like hey um we're gonna go back to you
know one of the guys places and watch
the game of Thrones Season Finale oh you
want to come with meanwhile hours before
Aaron and I we're trying to figure out
how we're gonna watch Game of Thrones
cuz in Ireland you know HBO Go is not
the same there are all these different
uh you know regional blocks and [ __ ] so
we look at each other not even a second
thought
hell yes so we go back to the strangers
house get pizza and wine and watch Game
of Thrones with like a bunch of these
people we just met at a bar and like
anywhere else that could that would
never happen in the US only in Ireland
that Irish hospitality that was the
coolest night on our vacation and then
you know like that it was just kind of
downhill from there all right no but we
had a lot of long story short life is
better in Ireland and shout out to those
people you names oh man don't I got I'm
sorry
what are the names [ __ ] lucky yeah
what's what a stereotypical Irish names
are lucky
that's all I got lucky lucky shut up to
those guys
what champs champs yes to you look at me
what a terrible guest I am I didn't pour
you [ __ ] but you know what I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna bring a bottle of honey
that's what I like to see that's what I
like that's gonna be a long day my
friends pour short one and I've moved
smack before I'm really on cloud nine
goes quicker in the bloodstream that way
ya know that's why doctors that's why
they booth right when a doctor
recommends boo thing it doesn't harm
your lungs booth that hey hey hey ever
thought about booth I know you have a
drug problem yeah
everything about booth in that it's
healthy alternative looks like that
South Park episode were they right shove
[ __ ] up yeah that was the original booth
really was it really was if we drink all
that Hennessy this will be the last
podcast ever for any of us yeah let's
not do that sounds like a challenge to
me well we have three crew members here
you have any pens e to mix it with
yeah Henny and Pepsi Pepsi yeah you know
that old yeah
Pepsi Henny sorry oh sorry I didn't mean
to shout no mic guys I have to head
people complain when I shout so I have
to do like this yeah get the damn Pepsi
in here that's audio correct it later in
post no just go back it was minute 35 in
your you know three hour podcast yeah
yeah there you go just a note for the
editor and in in would you lower the
damn volume of me shouting at you tell
so you guys you guys getting slammed by
the D monetization monster I know
there's been like a round I just got
real [ __ ] by that you really but
thankfully tears by the way - oh yeah -
the poof - poof yeah I got boost into my
own D monetization mm-hmm really
that's a deep metaphor can you unpack
that um you know I got that idea
beautiful I got shoved up my own
channels [ __ ] to see what it looks
like when okay I go to the part site
that's some portal [ __ ] okay I make
money from okay so what what percentage
of your videos now like 90% 90% way are
you what can you rebuttal yes I sent
what what the [ __ ] is it call it say
appeal repeat that's it that's where I
meant to soar up he'll appeal what a
repeal repeal repeal repeal it replace
it oh my god you know I don't drink
straight what I only joking are you
kidding me he said peps the heading can
you please get the Coke Zero in the
fridge I mean I don't understand why I
have to ask you some boy Eric does right
I love Ian he's that he's actually
incredible he does so much first oh yeah
I say that because I have to but he's a
real nightmare no I died one look at him
you can tell you can tell he's actually
amazing yeah don't be me and you're
gonna get the monetised so I made a pact
with the devil I don't give the amount
of time really I don't know well you did
are we talking about the a in Thanks
all right we're good I I filled them all
it's still like it wasn't 90% and I
guess like I don't know what the [ __ ]
I haven't been keeping up with how this
[ __ ] works so I just woke up one day and
I noticed that all of my green money
icon said hello and I was like oh and
then I tweeted about it and then Adam
firm your movie sucks hit me up on
Twitter was like hey by the way you can
peel all those yes
and as I go in because most likely it
will all or most of them will be a river
I've been getting emails like every day
since then we're like four will be
approved for ads again and then another
four won't so okay so here's the scary
part about this that was basically those
were all already to all demonetized
since they had pocalypse as I understand
it they only just now are giving us the
option to appeal them that's right
that's right which is so if anything I
mean I don't want to assume too much but
if anything wouldn't that be a plus like
it being alerted you're being told so
they were already its monetized resized
or whatever but not a brother no damn
but I think I did hear I filled Franco
may have brought this up too but this is
like a while this was at the beginning
yeah the advent of the ad pocalypse
right months and months ago but
okay so at least at least you know I'm
not like more 50% now not more 50% well
every I think you're doing well because
now you know run like it's not like you
were suddenly hit with this unmonitored
but yeah yeah it seems like that which
is why there was like a new wave of
panic this past quarter was actually
just them again as always YouTube
doesn't know how to their PR is like off
the chain yeah their booth in like all
day if they were a TV network oh boy
they'd be great they'd get sued a lot is
this this is a kind of interesting
question are we as creators entitled to
something well no we're at we're at
their mercy
with all things and you do what we do
because it's fun and it's what we've
always wanted a lot right make a living
from it yeah that too but we got to see
who's able to pivot to like with the
podcast you guys have sponsors like that
cannot be demonetized and you got
patreon which a lot of people depend on
now and YouTube right yeah shout out to
Eric to shout out some good stuff on
there one of these days what's the
patreon.com slash comment ticket get in
there and help your boy out yeah
he's worth it it's like a book one
dollar a dollar a dollar give me a
dollar
listen but yeah I mean it's a good
question is worth like if you compare it
to like cable television
you have people making content and they
depend on it they're making their living
there right and I know it's it's kind of
this new [ __ ] right like we're all on
YouTube making a living and depending on
it and I know it's just a platform and
we all sign like a User Agreement when
we sign up but at a certain point do
they owe us something yeah I don't think
so yeah that's that's the sad part
yes is that you can't feel entitled to
anything that right that's the danger of
it you're getting will do and they don't
realize no yeah when YouTube first
started they didn't give people [ __ ]
yeah like it was just this place days
videos and then your sketch your
sketches but back then people just made
sketches because it was fun getting
popular was good enough
but when it turned into a career it does
suck to depend on something I have the
for fall out from underneath oh my god
this ad pocalypse was way worse than
anything I ever anticipated because like
me neither we're always like well you
know even if our channel dies and
everyone stops watching like will still
get like a certain amount of natural
revenue coming in right but that will
sustain us but like when that [ __ ] hit
initially know we lost like 90 percent
of our revenue and it was it was
mind-bending yeah cuz it's like who
knows what you had planned like it
really yeah of course I know what your
income is gonna be and if you go you
know as many months as you have gone you
can predict [ __ ] surprise right like
that's we're always like well worst case
scenario even in the event of ahead Paul
coops will make this much right but it
was way less as well I heard it folks
the most people up channels like you or
is even smaller who are like just coming
up maybe read they're making a couple
thousand dollars a month and they're
like dope I'm gonna quit my job right
and then that happens and then what now
what yeah yeah I mean luckily I have
those other things going on cuz if I was
just depending on you to Britt I
probably wouldn't even be doing it if I
was just depending on YouTube revenue
you're full-time now right yeah because
you have MIRR cube at patreon merch
patreon and the the ad revenue I'm gonna
see I guess next month what the actual
hit was but I'm guessing it's negligible
really I I mean like ever since the
merchant yeah patreon and everything
like that I've been looking at the
YouTube stuff like it's extra that's
where I was in the beginning it was the
main meet that's the best way to do it
yeah up until recently that for us it
was always like we lived and died by
Adsense and now until recently like we
opened our own merch store and then with
the podcasts now we're finally starting
to see it as like a bonus like you know
that which is I think honestly it's the
one that flew yeah these this days you
got it you can't depend on that show
right no yeah so hey all those new
creators out there looking to get a
YouTube channel don't bother
up there nah then that it seriously
started patreon Channel right right
before the YouTube just it's gonna be
smart uh [ __ ] oh yeah we're all
[ __ ] broke yeah I'm doing I'm doing
our thing we're all doing alright
yeah how much you pay for yours this was
fifty bucks
that was our ours was you got a deal I
think mine was either 40 or fink was
fifty forty or fifty I picked up at
Ralph's so that's where we got ours nice
and round them boy oh yeah slowly you
know may as well pick up like some
toilet paper and some peat you know like
it's deodorant yeah I didn't oh I run
out of that all the time we uh we sent
our PA I'm so [ __ ] without ela we sent
our PA I says listen you have to get a
bottle honey I know Jax bringing it but
I need to match him so she goes she
brings back bubble honey and I'm like oh
Allah took my deodorant
I have no deodorant you have to go by do
I hear it because I didn't have time I
was running late of course of course you
have to yeah that's why you have a PA
that's why I have a PA to buy a mediator
so they come back they bring the dealer
I get into the office
I forgot the cameras Dan our producer
media looks at me the second I walk in
he's like you Dom into cameras you
worthless [ __ ] loser
sounds like you yeah like he's like
cackling now something like phase II
Listed give us more she's more of a care
but she's she brings the camera she
doesn't forget the [ __ ] cameras well
she took my deodorant
you should yeah sound sounds like
someone's in the doghouse when she gets
back Shh I am NOT gonna forget ver that
I know I showed you nor should you get a
hairy deodorant
it's not illegal I have Thor but listen
that's not I'm not saying it's weird
no I am look say it's weird or not it's
what it is it's just that feel like
there's different deodorants for
different sexes you know there is of
course you sexist piece of [ __ ] he's
the lady no I use Old Spice classic no
aluminium one [ __ ]
hey how you doing you know oh my
goodness you just dab yeah dab'll do ya
okay okay and so she tried all these
feminine deodorants and she didn't like
the smell she didn't like the whatever
you know didn't do it for her yeah and
so she starts she gives my debt she dabs
mine and she likes it you guys share
your your your Musk yes that is adorable
it really is that's a true love share
our Elon Musk I'm gonna like that lit on
fire
poor Skippy can I ash on your lint I got
here I want to share with you
let me first check on our hurricane
relief h3o then I heard of a king king
everybody's hating on the Red Cross Lily
do you notice that what no what's up
with Red Cross I don't really know I
mean when we were talking about doing a
charity everyone was like whatever you
do don't do the Red Cross memo there
where you start are you moving that
that's the Pope [ __ ] and his hat um
in answer to your question is they won't
be tricky I'm good I've heard that
before but I've never understood it
really this is like does a bear [ __ ] in
the woods like oh yeah it lives in the
woods right [ __ ] his hat I would [ __ ]
hope not it's a mess it's a clear yes
that's the point it's an absolute yes
does the Pope I I like also just the
Pope [ __ ] in the woods this is the Pope
[ __ ] in the woods yeah there's a there's
like a Rick and Morty episode I was a
guest whiff tea thing the president says
I really like someone asks the president
do you know how to fly this plane and
the president responds something like
that but it's like but but it's like a
weird variation and the other guy says
I'm not sure the president says exactly
just the Pope eat ass of a 12 year old
nobody's okay with it I've lost that
beef jerky
does the Pope [ __ ] jerk-off nightly
with the fleshlight yeah he does
guaranteed this wall [ __ ] in his hat
absolutely it's thanks practice yeah he
puts the divider up installed it in his
[ __ ] Pope Nabil future for those
dividers I'm telling you I have a man
forum all right let me let me first of
all I'm getting pretty toasty here oh
absolutely
you guys are the best yeah thank you so
much this is just what I needed when I
was watching him like a little bit
outside it was more like the YouTube
highlights of your the the hurricane
relief one with Marilyn and Alex and all
those guys I was watching some of that
with with Erin and I was like I can't
[ __ ] top this it's right like in
relatively speaking to like you know
this podcast and she goes no you can't
it's so like thanks for having there's
no listen about that one we planned a
lot that was awesome we put a lot of
work into that and like I think I mean
the prank call was was beautiful
incredible but I think the pinnacle for
me and from a technical standpoint as
well is that we got Justin to pepper
spray Joey yeah in the [ __ ] faith and
we got to watch it live on can you turn
it up I can't hear it then sound boy I
mean for the ages I think that was
probably the pinnacle of this show to
this to this day I mean it takes a lot
of cogs to make make something like that
happen so patch yourself in the back man
I've definitely always wanted to see
Joey salvia [ __ ] pepper sprayed so
there you go and now Joey wants to top
it he says he wants to come on again and
we can shoot him with a taser gun
Wow and I'm like I don't know I had that
ones getting into a liability for me
yeah I mean if he got shot by a taser
gun you can just keep doing his pranks
cops show up and shoot him with a taser
gun right you know room to eat into the
microphone by the way and I couldn't
even get oh now you're fine you're good
you don't need to move add f/4g are you
hungry should we get food
just putting down him you guys get
putting down a base layer you scream at
Ian oh yeah got the company credit card
and I know he [ __ ] uses it for
inappropriate [ __ ]
Ian I checked that statement every day
okay and it's a little shifty I'm
telling you sometimes I see [ __ ] and I
am watching you when we walked in he
asked if we wanted him to buy anything
like on Amazon with your bird he did I
told him is ask you that oh okay I
thought we that's cool
all right I got this article let me get
to my um that's a lot of fun face book
my favorite company yeah Facebook and
Abel's advertisers to reach jus haters
talk about targeted advertising now is
jus haters like an actual group or are
they saying just generally people I
choose yeah here let me show you um
wanna market Nazi memorabilia or recruit
marchers for a far-right rally Facebook
self-service ad vine platform add the
right audience for you let's see here
they enabled topics to search for such
as Jew hater
how do perm Jews boy or history of wide
Jews ruined the world I mean that's the
gist er II to that there's a hair it's
only austere the illustrious history
it's called the Bible it's called the
New Testament an old okay to test if
these ad core Gary's were real we paid
$30 to target those groups with three
prominent post in which a pro república
article or post was displayed in their
newsfeed Facebook approve of all 3s
within 15 minutes Jesus because they
paid them I love [ __ ] Facebook yeah
you could pay them to do anything yeah
yeah you want their the biggest [ __ ] on
the internet you want anything done you
want a booth Facebook that's where you
go for boobs yeah I got all kinds of
buffa nads up on facebook its
facebook.com slash biz I'm sorry you're
right you're right
they have a special landing page poufs
calm redirects to Facebook correct yeah
yeah Facebook's advertising has become a
focus of national
mentioned since it disclosed last week
that had discovered $100,000 worth of
ads place during the 2000 oh well all
this [ __ ] I was just with the G oh [ __ ]
yeah I didn't read this far in no no III
glanced at a headline or two that that I
had similar news to this so is this like
the new like YouTube promoting I are
like YouTube running ads on Isis videos
is that kind of like well it's kind of
different because when you when those
ads run on Isis videos basically YouTube
runs it in bulk so an advertiser says I
want to run my excuse me no I was in a
moment was like to ever press her do
embrace embrace okay so like yeah so you
know there's a bulk they says I want to
run my videos across YouTube and
YouTube's like cool h3 Jack film this
guy is demonetised but Isis got him yeah
but these guys are like I want to target
my dogs who think that Jews need to burn
an internal Hellfire really specifically
targeting the the hate groups yes right
mark Mark Zuckerberg does not have any
kind of filter in place where I call
burn the Jews yeah let's actually think
about this though is it immoral I mean
if there's a dollar there if there's a
marketing dollar there if there's people
out there who hate Jews it's not like
this is gonna change your mind well I
mean could I pay YouTube to make a video
about burning Jews what do you mean like
pay YouTube to go hey YouTube I'm gonna
make a video called
burn the Jews Nazi Party lol and I'll
give you like 25 bucks
would you to be like well 25 dot Amin
yeah but what you wanna I think before
they would now not and it would be like
a pre-roll ad before certain videos
right I guess it's the right comparison
here yeah before you could do that
actually you're saying before like that
populist yeah
now their systems are I've actually
found my own experience just putting Jew
in the title description or tags what
the [ __ ]
yeah that's a few
just say Jew like well also the LGBT
[ __ ] getting to monetize yeah what the
hell what is that right [ __ ] that's
some fifties [ __ ] right there
well that one that one's really
confusing to me because YouTube and
Google in general seem very diverse yeah
it's it's right against I don't think it
was intentional it's machine learning oh
that's the problem
yeah this from talking to people at
YouTube they actually the algorithm is
total run by an AI they don't even
understand what it's doing I'm not okay
with that it's spooky stuff I want to
take that [ __ ] AI down how do we
confuse that thing so much that it
commits suicide okay I commit suicide
I don't have you I've seen enough of the
Internet to know that like come on any
any intelligent being would want to
commit suicide interestingly enough I
have a whole article about how suicide
rates are up that I want to talk to you
guys oh yeah and I don't think AI would
be excluded from that no I would push
for getting AI as sad as possible yeah
yeah there was this a robot in Futurama
that was like programmed to be suicidal
yes in that one no who's a sad robot
that's now I haven't seen that episode
huh listen we're gonna take a break and
we'll be back that was a such a
non-sequitur buzz Dan was just like 45
minute alert everyone call your
therapists yeah everybody moms come back
from our sponsors who make this show
possible so don't skip it you son of a
[ __ ] and let me tell you what else
that shit's funny I make it entertaining
and I make it a joke your ads you've got
the best ads deal yeah are you wearing
him now do you almost did I didn't want
to wear him because you guys would asked
me to see them and to show you but they
don't all come brown and then and then
you get demonetized the old thing
no that's fair Eric doesn't know how to
pose pain yeah oh that's speaking of
bathroom etiquette I know we're about to
take a break but I walked in on a guy
doing that in a bar bathroom right I'm
in this bar for a guy's birthday like
butters I [ __ ] yeah like butters it's
what I thought of when I saw I walked
into the bathroom and I thought the
stall was clear cuz when the when
there's one person at the urinal I go to
the stalls so I opened the stall and
it's this guy with his [ __ ] pants
around his ankle and his underwear I
just like I like you know getting know
he's peeing you said he was asked was
facing his ass was facing me he wasn't
wasn't unlocked was not mind you to walk
you know he wanted me to walk in on him
and then I saw him later that night and
I was like man you you can I saw your
[ __ ] but up in front today no I
didn't confront them in distance you saw
him yeah yeah it's just like something I
knew about him I didn't want to know
right yeah there's a smooth as smooth
smooth guys we have the best sets so
that being said see you in a brief
moment all right okay now I'd like to
give a quick thank you to our sponsors
without their help this show would not
be possible quip it is a slammin hot
toothbrush it vibrates it's slick people
are calling it the Apple of toothbrushes
but without the big price tag this is a
an electric toothbrush that is a slick
tiny little vibrating tube and it's
actually really nifty because it keeps
time you brush your teeth it lets you
know every 30 seconds it stops
automatically after three minutes it was
named invention of the Year by times
magazine come on
I actually loved it a lot I'm always
searching for toothbrushes that aren't
too harsh and aren't too soft and let me
tell you something about quit they hit
it right
you can even subscribe to receive a new
brush head on a dentist recommended
three month plan for just five dollars
including free shipping qyp is backed by
leading dentist and was named yeah Oprah
loves it too apparently so quips starts
at just 25 bucks and let me tell you
good toothbrushes are expensive I just
spent 60 bucks on toothbrushes on Amazon
trying to find the best one I'm like I'm
like Goldilocks too hot too cold clip is
just right go to get quip comm GE T Q u
IP Cobb slash h3 right the flip now you
get your first refill pack free with
your equip electric toothbrush if you're
obsessed with oral hygiene or maybe you
just want to get a fresh clean kiss for
that person in your life I'm telling you
give it a shot you won't regret it I do
love and endorse this product take you
quit all right stitch fix here we go if
you're a lot like guys you could
probably think of a million things you'd
rather be doing than shopping for
clothes proof that hits home between the
parking and crowds at the mall and the
endless browsing and lack of advice
online it's enough to make you want to
rock the same t-shirt and jeans forever
I'm telling you I don't I don't change
I'm dumb I'm Doug funnie these people
are talking right to me
but you can't because women so let me
tell you about stitch fix men they're
reimagining how to find and buy clothes
and you never even have to leave the
house it's that easy just go to stitch
fix calm and tell them your sizes your
favorite types of clothes and how much
you want to spend and apparently they
proud they also have the size that fits
my fair unique body type which is both
fat and skinny at the same time and I
know I'm not the only one out there
gentlemen your personal stylist thing
gets to work hand picking new clothes
for you based on your style and budget
it's like the girlfriend you don't have
she can address you it's beautiful you
have a girl dress you so that you can't
get the girl
five items are delivered right to your
door you try them on at home and you
only pay for what you keep shipping's
free both ways so anything you don't
want you just send it back and exchanges
are always free too
you can get your fix monthly quarterly
or whenever you feel like it there's no
subscription required it's easy the
shipping is free why am i give them a
try I promise you'll be hooked call to
action that's I'm not supposed to read
that part get started now at 2:00 stitch
fix comm / h3 you'll get an extra 25%
off when you read when you keep all five
items in your box that's stitch fix comm
/ h3 get started today guys if you can't
like me and you can't trust yourself you
need a girl it's a it's a catch-22 you
need the girl to get the girl stitch fix
is that girl that helps you get the girl
she doesn't want you trust me she's got
bears thing to do
she's got a guy who's jacked and he
dresses great don't even try to get hurt
you want the other girl and she but
she's gonna help you get there okay go
to stitch fix that cough slash h3 get
25% off when you keep all five items
thank you to them and finally we've got
for all my lush is out there can I get
away oh we've got week now wink is a
wine straight to your door service you
go on their website you take a survey
what kind of flavors do you like when
you're sipping wine you like earth do
you like dirt
do you like skittles these are not
questions that aren't well earth earthy
is one but I'm just trying to give you
guys an idea they ask you all these very
sophisticated do you like chocolate do
you like coffee stuff like this and
they're gonna analyze your palate and
give you the best damn wine out there I
don't know what I'm doing when I go to a
wine selection there's all these slow I
like drinking wine I don't know how to
pick it Capisce week understands this
that's why they started the company to
give access to exceptional wines from
around the world so you can have more of
these special moments with the girl
who's gonna say the girl you're going to
meet
and you dress and the nice clothes I'm
just talking about the whole package
we're getting you a girl just go to try
wing comm spelled T ry winc comm take a
brief palette profile quiz now your time
is wasted fit fitting in a run to the
store now - your time is wasted fitting
in a run to the store that makes sense
because wink bases the wines are did
they send you around your taste
preferences a week will even introduce
you to a new rare and custom wines that
are not available anywhere else I tell
you the dang story behind each one it's
gonna get you laid let me tell you about
this exotic wine bottle in this fresh
new look
listen joint for free guys skip any
month cancel anytime and they have a
hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed
so you never have to pay for a bottle if
you don't like it ok now check it out
for our listeners right now wink is
offering $20 off your first order when
you go to try wink comm /h 3 let me
spell it and they'll even cover the damn
shipping TR wide winc try week.com /h 3
get $20 off your first order plus the
shipping is on the house it's free you
don't like it
ya don't pay guys so let me tell you if
you want to support the show considering
supporting one of our sponsors if you
want some wine if you need some help
getting dressed you want to try to find
those cuties and if you want to clean
your mouth I mean this is really a whole
package deal guys you're gonna get laid
these is the gettin laid experience so
thank you to our sponsors for making
this show possible and thank all you
guys too for supporting our sponsors and
now back to our scheduled program oh my
god
I mean those sound great man those
sounds all how're those needs
great absolutely this is the best
pre-recorded hey hey I just saw him do
it
it was live as [ __ ] this was live as
[ __ ] yeah man
sign me up you guys really doesn't
really matter look we know we've
recorded it today because I know I was
getting drunk with these sumbitches and
there's no [ __ ] way I could have done
those reads sober and a company of these
gifts ters and boosters right would you
rather it just cuts through an actual
commercial for the company or the person
talking about it that you tuned in to
watch I know I know you whining [ __ ] we
have the best copy than we do the best
ads how much did you enjoy that type
hundred ten fingers I was watching on
twitch while I took a [ __ ] during that
seven minutes
god bless here it was great it was great
right it's good interest all the things
tie whatever they were yeah no I got all
I got them all tie the Pope bouffes and
his [ __ ] flashlight while [ __ ] in
his hat in the calmest if you like that
copyright does a good hole flashlights I
think the answer is obvious
let's check it yeah there's a couple
Bush you know I have to drop a couple
drops left the honey I have to
compliment our intern who is really he's
getting good we got water yes yes shout
out yeah me neither
so no no thank you someone now what I'm
thinking are you hungrier oh this is
vodka yeah right yeah naca DEET Jack
doll I know you're like a dainty little
[ __ ] but tell me you'll eat some pizza
if I order it
oh you want you to figure I'm trying to
yeah gain about ten pounds since a
Europe so you really uh oh dude a couple
of pints of Guinness today
that'll do it that's the trick Guinness
is a trick I mean I I hear you but as I
understand it Guinness is one of the
lowest calorie beers I don't have it
backwards you have it backwards like
drinking a hamburger Guinness is a meal
it's like honestly it's like 400
calories a pint something like that yeah
can you fact check that I've actually
curious what are the calories I'll get
us not to under by please Jen oh I would
like that too because I'm I'm
I read that before but I wanna be an
Alexa in here I do his name is Dan look
that up oh yeah even better even better
but yeah dude all we all we did every
night like we would just go out to pubs
and just drink Ballmer's again it's
polymers and Guinness and just every
other at a great time oh my god it was
in live music every night about golf Oh
Galway Ireland I have a I have a I have
a feedback from Ian to intern he says
that it is a 125 calories per 12 ounces
but 12 is a big boy 1 isn't it notes
while a pint would be 16 so an is 8
ounces or oh do I have it backwards it's
12 no I think at all can of guinness is
like 12 like one of those like like
longer taller cans of Guinness and a
pint of Guinness would turn it
traditionally be 16 ounces so that oh
you're ready towards 200 yeah so I'm I'm
weighing why I thought it was like
[ __ ] 400 I really did I was like so
sure like opining but 200 is surprising
- that adds up when you have like ten
beers great collateral caloric intake
for the day yeah absolutely absolutely
in that game over
I'm sip I'm always surprised by how many
calories is an alcohol so you always so
whenever I go wow I mean like but before
I I always try to be economically
conservative not so much with the price
but but more so with the a caloric
intake like like what's the alcohol to
calorie ratio you know what I'm saying
so instead of like six beers how about
one Long Island iced tea or just
straight shots right and that's more
efficient and it does save money I think
in the yes what Long Island as opposed
to six beers I'm about drunk and
efficient I do love beer I love it I
don't it's a fantastic little invention
I don't love what's your favorite beer
one more light what you just broke is
bring in some bud light's when you're
done order a [ __ ] pizza for a bar in
here when we say what's your favorite
beer like when we say like go grab a
beer what's what's your go-to beer for
the night my go-to beer you know the
beer I really like is rolling rock
because it's seven dollars for a 12-pack
at my liquor store that's pretty nice
and that is that's stupid you're not ten
bucks that's
unbeatable aw man again
I swear to you I've read that gas is on
the light side I am shocked
I thought doubts but it's a little it's
low on on alcohol percentage yes it is
if you're trying to get [ __ ] up you
don't you don't try love kisses but it's
just it's really you don't you only I'll
tell you this you'll only like really
shotgun a Guinness when you're doing car
bombs yeah you know which which was
really fun to ask for in Ireland we
always tried so you don't do that
you don't ask for a [ __ ] car bomb
when you're in Galway our lobby well
yeah it doesn't sound right it's like
asking for a 911 and you I got 11 what
does you do in Irish accent what's that
you doing an Irish accent that let me
get a nice car let me get a right here
car bomb so what you know it isn't in a
car bomb though right it's a it's just
so it's half a pint of Guinness so they
you know it's it's a it's a pint glass
but they only feel at half with Eunice
okay and then you take a shot glass
that's half Bailey's and half Jameson
whiskey right and then you you literally
try it like a Jager Bomb
you know you or any any in each slammer
you just you drop the shot glass into
the into the half pint of Guinness and
you chug it before the Bailey's curdles
right that's and it's delicious it
actually tastes really sweet because the
bay leaves it kind of tastes like a
chocolate least we can do that really
yeah don't tempt me because I am are you
supposed to refrigerate that no not you
don't have to you don't have to really
yells all the germs I thought there was
the sugars or something about the
Shogun's it's better chilled but it's
not a pastor like a requirement it's not
a health issue thank you yeah whatever
the [ __ ] I was doing magic I thought you
were the alcoholic err I mean I always
refrigerated my Bailey's you got a drink
well yeah we do we try to do but you
don't
turns out you don't have to I don't have
to ok well that'd save some space for
other booze
sure it does alright I feel like for a
911 drink is there any like sir is there
a national drink for Saudi Arabia it's
called the uh they called the hi
it's called the hijacker
it's a shot in Saudi Arabia because that
should be the offensive but just bear
with me and that's just what came to
mind all right
it's a shot of vodka with 12 raisins in
it the hijacker I don't know weird make
sense they were I don't have to unpack
that oh okay now right all right you can
do a whole like you can do a Saudi into
a 9/11 you be [ __ ] up the whole party
will be Slammy undies has just pulled
out my undies has nothing to do with
this episode I love you no sorry let me
tell you something about me undies I
have soiled myself in that underwear so
many times because of this lush
beautiful soft fabric it washes right
out
that's incredible they don't write that
in the copy but this is the special
sauce well now we know yeah it comes
right now yeah we lost them they're back
they're back I will say your hat is dope
I know that's part of the bar Avila's
line yeah that's good that's so we
actually changed it in the final product
this is the pre run well it's not very
difficult to type or something yes the
pros that we we moved the teddy bear
down having an inch okay the more we
wrote Teddy fresh on the back oh that's
nice
that's really really nice I can't wait
Oh ILA's been working so hard on it so I
can imagine yeah that's that's no small
business running a whoo I'm actually
super excited that's really go and when
did you say it was dropping you know the
end of this month or the beginning of of
next one it's gonna be here before you
know it but after that I think it's
gonna be on a regular cycle we hired
like a [ __ ] superstar production
manager and she is like a freakin god
she's so great oh yes we were were we're
taking it seriously yeah yeah as you
should know I actually wear a hat if you
guys send me yeah oh yeah yeah I just
noticed you're not in the Hat Club today
no I'm not that boy yeah I'm not either
but I'm really trying to sell these guys
don't people have large you look like a
trucker dude so it's like I'm not
truck it's not too bad right really
they're not too bad
oh now you're hip no no no no put it
back put it back 93 420 and there it is
yeah honestly [ __ ] trucker am I am I
wrong
well the Hat doesn't say trucker that
where does the Hat doesn't yeah I get
that I agree I feel sexy as hell I have
a little bit of hair like polka neatly
you sure do you had a lot of hair polka
dots but a lot man hair he's a trucker
that uses a glory hole yeah at the rest
stop
give me a trucker that doesn't all right
come on
it's that trucker that doesn't exist
thank you it's a meth and glory holes
that's what the trucking business it's a
lonely job it's a lonely job truckin you
know you got a fine love where you make
it truck or make love where you find it
finding glory holes Grateful Dead head a
song about that I wouldn't be sad know
that my dad made me listen make me boy I
love Grateful Dead
oh yeah so like when you turn on do you
there's such a weird tangent but when
you edit or write or whatever do you
listen to music or do you my wish I
could yeah I can listen to music when
I'm editing it's not attracting cuz that
audio same I used to love you
I just don't [ __ ] listen to like so I
don't know what's new anymore I know
it's topical anymore right because I
can't how about you would you find
yourself listen instead I feel like I
must have tinnitus or something yes I
can't listen to silence while I work I
might have tinnitus I just wouldn't but
you can't work without so I can't work
without music that's fast editing I'm
how do you do that I can go to Spotify
and I turn the volume down to like 25-30
percent so it's always a little bit of
you have like filler well big part
editing is you watch the entirety of
what you filmed and you single out takes
that you like and yeah but you have your
your video first off they're long
they're always like close to 10 minutes
if not past 10 minutes and there's a lot
there's a cutting back to you and typing
you and screen capture of you typing and
the sound of you typing there's so much
to edit for five passes and like the the
later passes where I'm like watching it
to see if the pacing is good five passes
is like I do that without music I mean I
often do more than that anything is the
most intense part for me oh yeah perfect
we're all perfectionist you know I
honestly think I'm a better editor than
I am a performer I hate
I [ __ ] hate Sam that was such a bad
that was like that's pretty [ __ ] bad
this was these two guys you can't P it
in X you're and I'll doing a high-five
great minds man great minds but it's so
true I hate putting on the camera and
recording yeah but once I'm done I'm my
master you're the master right you're
the master of your own domain you you
because it's your once the editing once
you open up the software yeah you can
turn a trainwreck into a [ __ ] pile of
gold it's all in the timing it's all
have you guys ever made something that
someone else had to edit yes
how [ __ ] annoying is that and I give
any give notes yeah I don't do it a lot
every once in awhile you know it's
kneeling okay so for this one can I it
like I don't like that because in my
head you know and you don't wanna spill
it out for someone and it takes time you
just don't know cuz when you have
control of your own footage you know
that if you don't like anything that you
said or if you don't like something you
can cut it out and you can make it work
mmm but if somebody else is the master
of your footage you're saying you did
like a cameo and then you leave the
editing up to someone else oh you're
just saying like a cameo because like in
your guy's case I trust you completely a
hundred percent like anytime I film with
you guys I get on like yeah that's gonna
be funny um but like someone that you're
working with maybe for the first time
you it's going to an actual editor in a
studio not the person that you made it
with mmm like I did this interview with
Vice land about salvia right a couple
like two years ago or something like
that and when I was done with this
interview I realized that like I was
kind of acting in the way I act when I
filmed myself where I can like cut out
all the bad bits mmm where I sound like
a [ __ ] and I was just like walking
around drinking beers with these guys I
like slammed the whole six-pack during
the interview haha sweating my [ __ ]
face off oh yeah like we were in this
back room where the Sun comes in and I
was sweating so bad during the interview
and I was like guys can we go to another
room and I was like all that footage is
still fair game like if it were me I'd
all that [ __ ] but they don't but you're
but yeah of course fully it's still I
feel like I came across as not being a
complete brush it like they did at it in
somewhat it's like Airy young they leave
you're like oh that was it that's a lot
of faith you're putting all those faith
in their hands
you got a scary you have to be super
aware when you're like we did the
segment for hot ones right yeah right
where we've done like something that's
serious where someone else was gonna add
it in and I've worked with editors and
like for our own videos anxious never
works I've tried and tried and tried I'm
like okay [ __ ] it I'm resigned that I
have to edit my own guys are good at it
you know what works it's super
time-consuming but it's like you know
you gotta do it right yeah yeah so in
this case they have I don't know their
production is insane I mean they did a
great job editing it hot long yeah and I
think I was pretty good thanks
mm-hmm but I you know I trusted them to
take care of that and they did a good
job yeah but it's yeah it's it's scary
you don't know you don't know how you're
gonna come across yeah like um I guess I
don't know where the hell I was going
with this I think it was and can did you
guys get a pizza Dan can you boys of God
just confirm those pizzas on the way is
on its way
okay Oh Dan nice Oh sultry Dan what the
[ __ ] I'd ask you to turn me on nah we
sound like you know prepubescence in my
ninth grade I can't be next 20 years
later it's true yeah I'm gonna just be
[ __ ] in urinals when I'm 45 it's
gonna be like this 40 sorry that feel
like relatively young I like yeah I have
so much respect for people who jump in a
urinal I mean who do you know that does
that though like I mean I saw one three
the married oh really
anyway I think it was the special ed kid
but I was like damn it
this kid is his own man this kid doesn't
care the year that the you know what
privacy like he'd say he says you know
what not only will I pee next to someone
I said your honor I will [ __ ] and I'll
stare them in the dead of their eyes one
separate
and [ __ ] oh right no man and you know
the janitors got to come with some
disposable gloves smash it down yeah you
think you would scoop it up but he was a
great time he just takes the the great
out of the you neural so do you guys
want to play some Skippy's a few big
cares or no um I mean [ __ ] it man I'll
do it what smoke it you want a bit yeah
boof it yeah turn it into a shirt I
think like you know really complete the
circle of life look like although it
seems as if Skippy only wears gray
shirts I'm not seeing much color in
there think something happens in their
word just loses right like what happens
the decolorization zip it simple yeah I
mean come on man we please get on why
all lint looks gray when we all know
that you know not all fabric is great
yeah I got a question about Vsauce hell
yeah
why the [ __ ] did they start every video
with fee sauce who are they talking to
oh I actually have the awesome I'm ollie
really so actually yes I know the answer
he gets he actually as I understand it
gets annoyed when people think that
they're Vsauce the real truth is that
the audience is Vsauce interesting as
hey Vsauce Michael here well they have
to explain why feeling the world Vsauce
actually they never impact that means
I'm like Michael I get it but you have
to unpack that there's no more questions
you don't call yourself Vsauce the name
of the channel if you're not it's not me
right right right right
[ __ ] sake how are Y V sauce I hope he
watches this Michael you [ __ ] you
Michael Michael you sumbitch you get it
together he's such a good guy though
okay it's really slacking I'm gonna myth
busted [ __ ]
what is Vsauce but the booth blood right
out of your [ __ ] [ __ ] I got a
question for you if V stands for virgin
I think that's Vsauce boom roasted boom
cannon
yeah the the lint is what I'm pointing
to oh I thought you just meant the whole
audience of visa ya know I bet they [ __ ]
which would be really they [ __ ] Tory I
bet you think Vsauce has gotten my
kool-aid I mean he's married no I think
he's been a long-term relationship for a
while yeah so maybe I'm so totally ah
yes hundred percent what about those
other [ __ ] I think like I think
that Jake [ __ ] like crazy yeah I think
so yeah Vsauce got me laid oh do tell
well go on here we go
the gears are turning a gentleman never
kisses and so oh but on the podcast he
does yeah why what did you support what
a cocktail I have a question yeah we've
done previously
Erick's conspiracy corner and I know you
had I mean not necessarily a whole
conspiracy corner but you did have a
story about like radio beams yes
scrambling brains yeah that I've loved
the hell out of this is one of the
craziest things I've what can I pull it
out real light type type in Cuba sonic
attacks and it's it's one of the more
recent stories I think I could probably
point it out so this would be the
Guardian this is a legitimate news
source that's the that's the most recent
is scary I did some of this on the uber
ride over it's pretty pretty terrifying
[ __ ] yeah speaking of vsauce [ __ ] I want
to see this episode so tell me ya know
how does that photo you can hurt people
with sonic audio wait what you mean that
the the high level rundown what this is
all right so I mean there was [ __ ] in
this article that was news to me even
though it I've seen this new story pop
up a couple times but apparently there
were people in an American Embassy in
Cuba who like one guy woke up in the
middle of the night and they're just
like a grinding noise in his ears and
it's [ __ ] like crazy noises driving
him crazy he jumped out of bed and it
was gone he was like oh whatever and him
went back into bed and started up again
like as if they're I think in the
article says an invisible wall right in
his room
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's a wingding he did one
thing and a bunch of people got [ __ ]
up I don't know the number but there was
anyone 21 is what I recall it's a Bond
villain thing yeah used sonic weapons to
[ __ ] people's brains up and there's
lasting effects like loss of hearing
people have trouble with certain words
yes
balance issues that sometimes the brains
brain swelling they're calling it a
because it's going to happen it's really
scary [ __ ] nobody knows what it was
right right why diagnose it but they
don't [ __ ] they that know the extent
and they're skeptical long ago did this
happen by the way can we check an R yes
cuz I feel like it was a long time he's
best
well this article is just posted
yesterday okay and here's the thing the
guardian this isn't like Bob's [ __ ]
flat world journaled is is the gardenia
so this is actually real Ally and this
is I mean this is from yesterday at
least some of the incidents were
confirmed to certain rooms with
laser-like specificity and some victims
now have problems recalling specific
words the blaring grinding noise jolted
the American diplomat from his bed and a
Havana Hotel he moved just a few feet
and there was silence he climbed back
into bed inexplicably the agonizing
sound hit him again it was F he as if
he'd walked through some invisible wall
cutting straight through his room yeah I
knew that I'd [ __ ] nailed that yeah
there soon came the hearing loss the
speech problems symptoms both similar
and altogether different from others
among at least 21 you called that number
21 damn us victims in astonishing
international mysteries still unfolding
in Cuba the top US diplomat has called
them health attacks is this like a new
like yeah is health attach the new
warfare I mean like granted only 21
people in the world have been reported
you know the victims of this but I feel
like that's a really scary it's kind of
like what was it like World War one had
like mustard gas attacks that was the
big like scary warfare thing now [ __ ]
health attacks with laser-like precision
yeah as if they're only couldn't like
they're only controlling the bed or
whatever like the area in the diplomats
they
yeah they say in the article that the if
this is on purpose and this is an attack
right and everybody who got hit was
supposed to get hit the machine that
would be necessary for this would be
hard to transport like it would be big
and this [ __ ] right and Manhattan
projects but Cuba's crazy man like
that's the way the Cubans made this I
think it's Russians Russians yeah I mean
there's probably several very big
Russian presence in Cuba yeah
considering that's where they were gonna
nuke us for you back out sixties well
yeah you know back the year the Cuban
Missile Crisis there communists oh they
love ya yeah you know when our parents
you know when everyone hated Russia
instead of apologizing for the not today
yeah right well now Russia is no big
deal yeah yeah dude have you seen Putin
I call I don't call him Putin I call him
Putin yeah you seen his ass shirtless on
a horseback yeah he looked good justic
majest
I would say it I mean I hope he's a
twenty term Peter yeah I bet he was a
little twink when he was younger I bet
he got passed around probably boof so
much [ __ ] I'm trying to get us hit by a
sonic attack so we take up forever to
vlog it around [ __ ] giant machine I
hope so I hope it's not easily
transportable look the Cubans it's not a
rich country they're not developing
death beams no say so you just like got
cool with them yeah we're all good we're
gonna give him a ton of total bono make
like didn't know bono work visit like
wait wait where's ago Obama lifted the
travel ban yeah but didn't tron right
recant it did he that just sounds like
something he'd do I don't know if he's
actually done it I better confirmed that
I but like he's gone down the list of it
cuz Obama did that pretty late into his
presidency so yeah I think Trump's still
like around the first term of undoing
everything that Obama did right he
hasn't quite gotten to the second term
you are you sure there's an order though
in terms of what Trump's undoing I feel
like it's just all kind of the same well
listen to this suspicion initially
focused on a sonic weapon and on the
Cubans you have the diagnosis of mild
brain injury that sounds so much fun
yeah
considering unlikely to result from
sound has confounded the FBI State
Department's in us intelligent agencies
involved in the investigation some
victims now have problems concentrating
or recalling specific words several
officials said the latest the latest
sign of more serious damage in the US
government initially realized the United
States first acknowledged the attacks in
August 9 months after symptoms were
first reported nine months this is
spooky ass [ __ ] right this is like this
hanging here nine months or level this
is a really a conspiracy i me the the
u.s. department at FBI is acknowledging
that it exists this isn't this is a
relay no X file yes we're sure yes right
I need sure I need you're Sherlock you
were to cracking the case on the way all
right my violin into me
what's it lucky lucky come buff me
almost spat over all your cameras that's
oh my god so you don't take this [ __ ]
seriously enough I feel like this has
been in the news for a couple weeks I
never heard this till you brought it to
our attention it's [ __ ] crazy
they have sonic weapons that they're
shooting at us in real I don't want to
get hit what do you think like in the in
the front line of a potential war our
new war that these zaps would be I don't
think this would be the front line I
think this would be the way that they
used it here they hit an embassy you
know if you could get this in space from
a satellite
imagine hitting that bond level we're
talking like a [ __ ] go [ __ ]
what's the space one is that but yeah
we're like a Moonraker like levels of
tearing if you could incapacitate
somebody's brain to the point where
there's permanent damage
from like the blocks these are all you
would do it although just makes it just
walk two feet to the left and you're
okay yeah right yeah once you leave down
here I guess I don't go to your bed yeah
oh winter you go back to that bed quick
come on add in all of the weather look
at it it's probably quite warm there
yeah I love old cars it's all they have
yeah yeah sorry took me a second you
don't know
we have new technology mmm we can take
callers oh man we've got oh
Cubans only we've got re-own and milk
let's bring him in soon they're gonna
say hey milk boy talk to me tell me
what's good what's it great how about
yourself
we're doing adult things adult things
adult themes what's good yes yes what's
good guys my question is if you guys
could have a shot of hennessey with
anyone in history who would it be and
what would you guys talk about would be
with these two fellas they talk about
what we're talking about right now
uh Cheers oh love you boys yeah fill er
up yeah why should a stop play what is
this uh we're some in here yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh nice I like that honey bud but
but one sec sorry this is a multi party
answer oh yeah oh yeah just you know the
dirt on top of the beer cans is going
into my beer now that's right
cheers this is what I would thanks for
the question appreciate you but actually
I think if I could take a shot of Henny
with anybody it would be Kurt Vonnegut
Kurt Vonnegut yeah okay so so what
slaughterhouse-five oh my god he's he's
my favorite author but yes that's one
that's probably his most famous book
yeah yeah cat's cradle
slaughterhouse-five mother night okay
okay so why why him and I'm really I the
only reason I know of him is because I
was required to read his works and some
of his works in high school and outside
of that I never ventured beyond that
because we he says we humans live in the
third dimension we don't experience time
on like a scale and so they see the
fourth dimension like you us looking at
a mountain range every slice every
moment is something they can live in for
an eternity they live they experienced
the end of their existence and their
birth and everything in between
simultaneously and they can basically
decide which moments to live in what
what you know they have the dark moments
of their great moments and they can
focus on the ones that they enjoy but
they're simultaneously experiencing all
of them and
got such these wonderful sci-fi things
that unpack such huge thoughts and he
served in World War two he was a huge
political figure a great thinker he had
like the best interesting things to say
about the time I'd love to hear what he
had to say about the time the [ __ ] we're
going through now I don't know I just
really identify with him I think he's a
great guy a great a great man I really
want to read that lifetime smoker died
at the age of like 92 when he tumbled
down the stairs smoked and drank his
whole [ __ ] life a pack of Lucky
Strikes every goddamn day Jesus died
tumbling down the stairs at 92 living in
September that late 80s Early 90s mm oh
god man lucky guy is such a [ __ ] ah
such a legend I don't know would you
guys drink with hmm I would drink with
Hunter as Thompson that's a good and he
would show me how to shoot guns Oh Conan
she added them do you see the Randy yeah
he has a shootout with his neighbor I've
seen the block incredible yeah yeah he's
just like I was bowled out the context
was can you send me that link one of you
go out there
yeah like hunters Thompson shoots it
neighbor should pull it up they're
literally shooting at each other like a
loud [ __ ] you you scumbag boom
that guy was on yeah literally blew his
brains out cuz he's like I'm just too
old for this world football season's
over or something like that was the name
of his oh you know yeah he's a [ __ ] up
dude right I don't want to be him and in
any respect whatsoever but we never
liked his life but the [ __ ] that he put
out was mmm when I was a young kid
looking for things to read to like
metamorphosize myself oh you're killing
it here's his stuff was anything at all
very helpful the way you talk is a
[ __ ] legend
[Music]
this son of a [ __ ] was a [ __ ] of
others calles over here and you know
they have no intention of that was weird
manner of speaking it's all very much
you know I talk about the dependence Wow
it's cuz he's always got a cigarette
holder in his mouth oh right right but
it like became part of his drawl you
know yeah yes such an interesting [ __ ]
guy and he was like he when 9/11
happened
he wrote this whole thing the next day
that called it called it all he was like
we're gonna go to war or Saudi Arabia
Iraq look some drunk yeah right
he called he called I think the three
countries that we ended up like [ __ ]
bombing Jim the immediate aftermath the
guy blew his [ __ ] brains out he made
like a pact early in his life he's like
when I turn I don't know how old he was
59 or whatever he said he was young he
called it early he said I'm gonna kill
myself at this age huh and he did so he
just ended up in his mind see I would
rather go to 92 and take a spill down
some stairs I mean after all I seems
better I I love the guy he smoked his
whole [ __ ] life in live tonight he's
and he took a tumble and he's pissed out
was he a healthy dude you know enough
about his mean he was thin he was very
tall and he smoked a lot you know the
fact that he could still walk stairs at
that age I envy that hurt in the well
apparently now you could you know is
they go stairs huh yeah no problem
got it oh I'm dead I'm thinking more of
the musician era so I would either want
to have a have a pint or a shot with Ben
Folds one of my wait isn't he alive well
yeah we can make that still in history
what was the question
like Dead or Alive I was just like
thinking about dead people yeah well
yeah yeah yeah you guys want the the
morbid
you know but no Ben Folds has been a
inspiration of my musically for decades
honestly I just love life he's awesome
he really is no I came to our College
years ago and just oh my god so I still
follow him you know so I did just all of
my like anything piano why's that I
write it's clearly ripped off Ben Folds
let's be real um and then second my
other inspiration that I would love to
have a drink with also still alive
Japanese composer Nobuo Uematsu he is
responsible for writing all the dance
offend yeah oh oh yeah it was that that
because the Bowie Mott so he wrote the
soundtrack for like the first ten Final
Fantasy games of which I've never played
Wow but listening to the soundtracks to
Final Fantasy got me into writing music
to begin with and smoke he's just like
yeah not beyond that I don't know a
thing about him I know like he he's
Japanese composer but you know he got a
lot of Western influences like Jimi
Hendrix and Led Zeppelin and such the
hell it's true story but you would never
know what listening to his music it's
not like his music sounds like Jimi
Hendrix it's all just gorgeous
orchestrations and it's funny because
like he's writing for like you know
8-bit 16-bit you know Super Nintendo and
regular Nintendo and then you can hear
his work evolved into PlayStation 2
where you can finally fit a full
orchestra to a CD and or DVD and it's
gorgeous and the guy like imagine
writing 60 70 80 hours of music per game
Final Fantasies 1 through 10 so
listening to his stuff you know really
inspired me I would love to just pick
both of those guys brains over a beer or
two and can you pull up one of his songs
I find that such an interesting medium I
get there was video game music I could
do a song right now
Oh better no I got it he did that dah
dah dah dah dah dah hold up I got some
Jill or Gil Gil I've never known how to
pronounce that yeah yeah it's Gil I
would say kill
is it gif or Jif it's the same [ __ ] okay
don't get me triggered it's a [ __ ]
yeah
yeah yeah I mean okay oh the original
person said gift get [ __ ] real [ __ ]
changes culture happens culture hack
culture will assume the right yeah yeah
Jeff Jeff Jeff sounds like a [ __ ]
place where you'd change your car oil
but it's also is a Gil it's Gil it's
good what what does that set the current
currency a fantasy okay I was the one I
played I have to tell you I mean I find
it very interesting that you've never
played the games but your huge fan of
the music would you say fascinating
someone gave me the soundtrack in eighth
grade to Final Fantasy 10 that was the
first ps2 Final Fantasy game never play
the game to this day never even touched
it and it's just the the opening theme
it's calling - I'm gonna butcher the I
apologize people in the in the chat in
the comments but Tuesday an arc endures
an arc and or whatever it's this
gorgeous piano composition and I taught
myself how to play it by ear to this day
I can't really sight read very well and
very slow at it but I taught myself how
to play it because I was so [ __ ]
moved and inspired by this piano piece
and now then that's that was the that
was the pivoting point for me that's why
I write music for all my videos to this
day man incredible so I guess there's
just some final fantasy 6 music ah the
Opera yeah a lot of people reference the
opera scene for Final Fantasy 6 so he
did all this huh wrote the whole
soundtracks a genius to everything has
he not done movies or anything like that
I'd imagine he's done I think he stabbed
an anime and got some and some films
like anime films but not not tradition
still play like Final Fantasy 7 songs in
my head yeah I can't do them with my
mouth like I did with the no but I hear
yeah yeah cuz usually things in there
they're hard enough yeah anime has
amazing music man guys I don't know
cowboy bebop dude you ever see oh yeah
yeah yeah have you seen hunter hunter
never heard of hunter under Islamic god
the music in that what's that what's the
it was a genre orchestral or guitar just
weeaboo anime hardly ever show yeah
that's about a bunch of kids with magic
and they [ __ ] [ __ ] up and they've
nothing like that the music what's the
music like like the instrumentation is
that like oh hell yeah and for a trip oh
my god one of these songs makes me
freakin jizz
dag I let see music can be so inspiring
yeah absolutely the same way that pros
can be inspiring you know music is so
much more accessible in a way than um
well it's universal pros you know you
don't have to think you'd have to do
anything you just sit back and enjoy the
read limit there's just one in
particular cuz I don't I don't think my
guy naboo oh he MOT so I don't think he
knows English I don't think he speaks
English but he doesn't [ __ ] have to
tunicate I don't know if this is the one
I'm thinking of are we on a card oh yeah
this is it
you know this shit's on another level
and some guy just made it for an anime
show right it's like the best song ever
I love that I love when people write
hits every TV or or or videogames and
it's the best
you know what I gotta run to the
bathroom I'm gonna run to the bathroom
and they keep this plane alright I'll be
back in a short two minutes those of you
who subscribe could enjoy the rest you
can watch on the [ __ ] commercial yeah
right figure it out
thank you very that came off harsh but
that's what it is we'll talk we'll talk
over yeah being jacquard doing the
commercial live yeah absolutely
so today's h3 podcast was a brought to
you by Hennessy Hennessy thank you
thanks Hennessy huge thanks to our Jose
and Hennessy what Rosa is that inner oh
this is uh note our eros name how do you
model that well you suitable
son-of-a-bitch and I hope I'm looking
into the right
you're not camera you're not it's
probably this one over here but god damn
you look good doing it hey Eric what is
your next while I got you here in my
podcast yeah what is your next video
going to do my next video was gonna be
called the Kids Corner I was gonna do
the whole thing like it was a kids show
I mean I saw a Chris Reagan video oh no
about the same [ __ ] no and I was like
you created it if you're watching this
Chris Reagan way to steal my friends
ideas on how telepathically [ __ ] you
yeah I met you a bit Kanye really cool
but [ __ ] you though the the mind pool
and took it preemptively but I I do have
a thing where if I'm making a video yeah
and it's happened with some of the Ethan
in ILA's videos too or if I'm in the
middle of writing a video and I see
another video that hits too many of the
same points yeah I bail a mouse socks I
thought a [ __ ] beanie was that Peller
top to lateral thinking I hate that you
know it's not even lateral thinking I
think I think he just got to it first
cuz it's something that obviously Elijah
but someone yeah yeah it's just too soon
and I I saw on Twitter he's making a new
ones so I didn't want to it was gonna be
so funny to I say you still make it man
[ __ ] I might still make on Twitter Chris
Chris Reagan has his voice yeah
comenta kit has his own voice right I
say you do it but I be more money yet
normally that wouldn't stop me but the
beats of his video were simply too
similar interests to what I was doing
that's really interesting
I hated the idea of sort of uh you know
getting into it yeah I hear you I hear
like it would suck to make a video that
cuz I was like I had finished writing it
already and then I saw his and I was
like oh [ __ ] did you shoot any no I
didn't you didn't see that's I just
wrote it okay but that's still annoying
but it could be a lot of music I'm not
against sending him like a DM and being
like hey man I'm gonna make this by DM
do you mean it I'm not ripping you off
do you mean a DMC by DM I mean D a CA
and just shut him up for life yeah it's
your [ __ ] property now baby now he's
cool I met immediately he's a nice guy
we're talking about how how Chris Reagan
just bouffes all day every day and just
like he's a grade-a buffer ya met I met
him yeah he's it have you met you met
Chris yeah that's what we're all
drinking together he's a cool guy
holy [ __ ] I like that I like him a lot
he seems like a good guy that was
honestly I keep saying oh my favorite
night of my favorite era of VidCon was
the night where I snuck out and hung out
the Hilton hotel with you [ __ ] that was
insane because I got everything else is
such a [ __ ] show that's the drunkest
I've been in years
dude that was such a murder I've never
been to VidCon I thought about going
this year but I was like you missed out
I don't know I we had a held down
everything Adam from YMS we had Chris
break you don't want to hang out with
all those guys but yeah I don't know you
have to hang out with the right people
otherwise it's oh so once once my
manager left I was off I I hated it I
hated like I didn't like like and I
loved I used to love VidCon every year
was like my [ __ ] Christmas in the
middle of the year really yeah hell yeah
I was all for it and then it just became
so corporate and so like disassociated
with what it used to stand for that
whatever used to stand for community
polka little hotel
room parties you know what I mean like
used to be the small thing where it's
like yo guys meet me at room uh three
one four and we'll just like crack open
some beers and chat now it's like hate
you got an invite to the this party the
studio71 bar exactly and it's just show
up and don't tell anybody no bar bouncer
can you not pull Do You Know Who I am
well that was the big well you you
caught me you talked about that whole
thing right the Instagram model yeah you
talked about VidCon and you're right and
oh yeah yeah yeah with the bull the logo
inside it well that and there was like
that Instagram model who like was a
whole you pull the whole do you know Oh
God dirty guard yeah yeah with like ten
thousand followers he can't board you
know oh yeah you could no oh god no no
no because because you do know who you
are but listen to this listen it's so
bad that just a couple of years ago it
was either I think it was Hank green and
we all know that Hank green one of the
co-founders know if not the founder of
VidCon I have no idea the [ __ ] that is
so there's a bit of a booth did I pay
him money you have to pay him off did I
pay him you paid him I paid him or some
way I don't know yet what about this
[ __ ] booth sir
so this guy so Hank green i I can't I
think he was telling the story he a
couple years ago was you know in line
for one of these parties maker party or
studios or whatever the [ __ ] collective
it's his it's his event it's his event
honey and he couldn't get to is that to
a party at his own [ __ ] then so great
and he didn't pull he's a he's a better
man he didn't pull a do you know who I
am
and I I'm sorry about it we all there's
no chance in hell we wouldn't pull that
card of course we would be like do you
know who I am we invented VidCon like if
we were interested his shoes I mean but
he did not and like I died that takes
great patience and control but can you
imagine if you founded VidCon and you
didn't get into a party at your own
convention I would raise hell yeah he's
getting paid though
but you couldn't it's his [ __ ] event
it's like oh cool it's so big that I'd
you know I just so you know i fishing
scrooge mcduck in his wall of gold I
feel
[ __ ] my Pope hat and show it to the
bouncer and go what do you think this is
do you know what this means
the Pope shits in his hat but at least I
get shits in his hat no I would be upset
oh yeah I know I'd be furious I like
that the point I'm trying to make VidCon
is it's a double-edged sword in one hand
it can be a lot of fun on the other hand
it's not as fun it used to be because
this is such it's bigger than well it's
as corporate I've never been and my only
my real pre woman I don't know how it
works no one ever reached out to us so I
was like I don't know okay I was never
invited so I don't even know like what
my axis would be cuz I'm just on the
floor if we would know that you wouldn't
have fun on the floor because people
would would swap you I'm not blowing
smoke up your no not like swamp yeah no
no I'm so famous this literally people
are there who are on you that's a fact
of the myth so clearly a lot of people
they know who we are
yeah so I don't have like any kind of
special access and like what my
experience was like seeing Logan Paul
you know [ __ ] setting up a drone and
setting up a mob and I'm like hiding
money and I mean the this last vid go
boy together
I need this piece where's the pizza yeah
take a shot that'll fix it um this last
VidCon was the first one I ever won -
yeah and I I went there and I walked
around in a sea of children for about a
half hour before I was like everyday I
might just leave like this is obviously
not my aspect is not fun it's not like
yeah yeah oh hell yeah I was like I went
to Google I was like okay closest bar
and I found the one and it was like
right there it was at the Hilton I was
like oh I'm going there then okay and
then like like I tweeted that I was at
VidCon and a couple people hit me up and
I was like all right meet me at the
distant bar yeah yeah and one only hit
that [ __ ] bar the whole time yeah I
never went back one of my buddies was
working there so here's okay that's
actually no I don't know that but here's
a deal with the Hilton bar that spot
exactly where I met you guys the name
where you were that used to be the hot
spot
for VidCon for years and years that bar
that exact bar that was like the because
that's where they put up all the all the
youtubers and all the creators and time
called yesterday
used to be there this is the first year
where it wasn't there they moved all the
if you had like a panel or a talk or a
meet up or whatever the [ __ ] they put
you all up in a different hotel that
wasn't in that whole little area by the
Convention Center you know I'm talking
about with the Hilton and it wasn't
there it was a drive away so you
couldn't like [ __ ] why I wonder why
they did that well I think just because
it's been so it's gotten so big more
privacy and also just gotten so big they
can't contain everyone and fans at the
Hilton anymore so they have to put all
the creators up so we this is the
formerly we rent like a couple of floors
and that in that Hilton okay
this year they rented out an entire
hotel purely for youtubers there's a lot
of money in that and that's fine and
it's just like I won so early on it was
kind of nice I'm not gonna lie like so
Aaron and I were there I was kind of
nice we would have like you know I would
have brunch or whatever with my manager
and we could just walk around freely and
whatever then it was night like all the
youtubers good but then later on like
man it just wasn't with all the parties
you know the the exclusive like oh you
got a wristband never spend for this
party going this thing tonight that's
when I was like [ __ ] this I'm gonna go
to the Hilton back when VidCon used to
be VidCon right that's where I met up
with you and Chris Reagan and all those
guys was so much fun and that was the
best night of VidCon that's great it was
the best night I think that part of that
is you you have to be 2110 to the bar
right yes no don't
apparently oh the Hilton bar yeah mmm
like a [ __ ] 17 year old could run up
and do a shot that you had just bought
some people it was crazy
well it wasn't on them there was this if
you look at schematics of the of the
table we were at it was so far away from
anybody was working there that hopefully
next time is a VidCon there they'll be
carting these [ __ ] kids at these
staples because I'll bet they took some
some measures to say yeah there's gonna
be some Schlitt some [ __ ] that slips
through yeah god we are I'm John we are
really drunk I'm a Heinlein here let me
do a segue here and let's just say we
got hit with an audio or
with the humans here or what guys I'm
gonna go I'm gonna lighten up oh no real
light real light subject man let's take
a hard segue here okay did you guys know
that suicide attempts in the United
States are way up no I did not
they're way way up what like this let's
lighten it up yeah this in the past
couple of years I was wanted to this is
turning into like an episode of black
mirror that bad we're having fun and now
we're gonna talk about suicide oh boy
heart heart sorry actually no I finally
to get funding from VidCon I think yeah
yeah first of all like these stats were
kind of I mean certainly interesting but
surprising a lot too so almost 1 percent
of women have attempted to that's what
that is one percentile of the population
people are told suicide attempt yeah and
and I've always heard that it's men who
are attempting suicide more go to be to
that statistic but it's actually
significantly more women double that
yeah it looks like twice as many ways
and then age rise yeah oh my god 21 to
the these young kids man 21 to 34 well
35 ours actually holy [ __ ] yeah geez and
then like this I'll show you what really
surprised me yeah
single people all distant this isn't
really surprising but let me show you I
know it shouldn't be surprised by this
but the poor people who make under
20,000 a year are way more at risk
yeah well I mean it makes sense but yeah
because you always hear people saying
like oh when I was born I was [ __ ]
simpler and happier right right I hear
that but apparently that it's
prostitution almost two percent good
lord
I mean that's really so 2 percent like
was so 1.6 percent of the if I'm if I'm
understand this correctly which I may
not be yeah what's the yeah what
the data like like uh I'm interested to
find out of what so like a sample n
equals 34,000 huh
actually I don't understand this chart
from being honest with ya yeah so this
is a pullout of one on the right one
thing you're gonna get out of this
podcast is uh we are you know you don't
know how to
we don't horseless in totally with the
foot dance somebody what's the
difference for these two columns because
you've got here I don't know if this is
like over all suicides up its up right
it's a buyers market yeah it's a it's a
killer it's a suiciders market but it's
[ __ ] terrible yeah what is going on
what's world yeah that people are just
deciding I'm gonna [ __ ] kill myself
well can you blame it on just the blame
it but if you for lack of a better term
can you blame it on just the uprising
global population you know more people
wants more sues its per capita it's a
percentage oh you're a so that isn't
reflected no no okay
well I'm looking at down so you see past
your mental disorders yeah that one's
really high uh-huh it's it's it's just
not knowing your place in the world
I think it's Carter okay your place in
the world yeah there's less jobs what is
the world it's harder to make
connections because we're all online
everyone's trying to meet people and
that's not real everybody like there's
never any reason to kill yourself no
ever no ever yeah you know whose bogey
had a really really awesome analogy on
Twitter the other day he said when you
like when you kill yourself you're or
when you commit suicide you are
completely limiting the option there the
potential for happiness like we death is
a guarantee suicide completely rules out
any potential for betterment
so why bother and I thought that was
like it was so concise was better put
than I just did but it was extremely
concisely beautifully put and I loved
that well there's this one line from a
Clint Eastwood may think it's once a
time in the west he says what's it like
killing someone and it's Apple world
killing yourself he says it's a
I think killing someone you take away
all everything they've got and
everything they'll ever have hmm so
you're doing that I mean but I mean I've
never been I've definitely been in dark
places in my life but I mean man you've
got a listen I can put myself there yeah
I mean we can't we yes like we're barely
qualified to talk about this yeah but I
mean do people have a right to kill
themselves no not unless you're like 92
years old and you're looking at a flight
of stairs like well there it is right
Bonnie guy style yeah I feel you you
laughed
I heard that laughs that's well assisted
suicide is certainly something yeah yeah
yeah suicide roller coaster or the
euthanasia is that an actual thing no no
I don't think it's an actual physical
that's all theoretical but I've heard
that yeah we're it's like 7 or so
loop-de-loops
each gradually alone you just like lose
it's sort of like pain painlessly yeah
kill yourself I've seen graphs of that
but I mean it's the crater that you
leave in your wake is is like in my
opinion not ever worth it but if your
life is so if you're just living in a
state of total misery and suffering and
torture
mm-hmm right is it is it is it a
selfless is it a selfish acts to take
your life and leave that that way yes
and that you think so yeah selfish it's
a [ __ ] selfish thing well what if
you're in such pain you're about lady if
this is sorry there's not to be a hard
left or anything I make a hard left but
Lady Gaga had to very recently cancel an
entire tour or a concert in somewhere in
South America because she was in so much
pain she suffers from a very uncommon
disease with um
muscle pain nerve pain something like
that and like that sucks
yeah you so imagine me and so yeah
that's a real thing I just saw on
Twitter the physical pain yeah yeah um
and I don't know if it's constant I know
I know very little about it but I heard
another pot another radio show something
about that though yeah it exists yeah
so I don't
that's why it for me that's when it
becomes really really gray well in a way
why you look at people with anxiety and
oppression who are living in constant
mental mental yeah right cuz we unlike
it we it's very easy for me and for us
to say like just selfish itself it's
like suck it up you know I'd really
conflicted with that it's like yeah like
we're not we don't experience constant
we're very fortunate you know I guess
but like we don't experience pain this
is this a human condition or is it a
symptom of like a sick world yeah that
people are so many people are choosing
to end their own I can't imagine anyone
kill themselves because of the world
it's all but it was the conditions yeah
it's the conditions that the world
brings like like I was saying before
that you have no you there's no purpose
to find for yourself there's no mate to
fund for yourself your house all things
you tell yourself it doesn't mean no but
I've heard it said there's like oh we
got pizza thank you and so there's like
there's there several factors my reason
to live thought we got pizza I can't
talk about depression right now but
there's there's several thank yous when
when talking about like did you guys get
pizza out there doesn't matter I'm
afraid uh what do you guys want out
there cheese oh you guys don't you mean
wow wow don't make me beg yeah like I
mean you know we could talk for hours
about the reason behind suicide and
really it's [ __ ] alien to us really
yeah all hope to do is just to be like
have you ever gotten a message from
somebody that's like hey I've been
feeling really down and you helped yes
in the most basic of yes examples like
you see something like that and you're
like oh well I don't know what you're
going through but whatever I did worked
you know what I take those message
with a grain of salt oh yeah really
because I don't think that someone who's
actually like clinically depressed and
suicidal look this is kind of Sarah I
mean I don't know a lot of people just
already crazy a lot of thing to do - so
a lot of people just want your your
attention mm-hmm and so and I take that
stuff of the grand stalkers I okay I
don't want to take over my head I hear
ya be like very easy for that Savior
though if you look at there's some
people out there who are like I [ __ ] I
have saved so many people's lives and
it's like I don't want to touch it to go
to my head right that's I'm just out
here I'm making videos if you think it's
funny and you enjoy it I appreciate that
but yeah you're not setting out to try
to stay fly right you're not you know
that's not the end game no it's a nice
you know I guess side effect or like a
bonus if it's true that's not that
that's not why you and I do I'm not I'm
not as [ __ ] Saint
no I'm doing my job yeah I mean the fact
that we're here eating pizza and talking
about suicide yeah I think proof that
we're not [ __ ] sore no matter you
shouldn't trust us I'll get you out of
any dark spots right but that comes from
within yeah absolutely there's like
there's like a couple of different major
things okay there's like employment
relationships that's all I can think of
I'll bet but certainly she's out there
it's hard it's a tough world I think
relationships are is a huge thing
because I feel like we've seen enough
movies and TV shows that we're all
entitled we're all entitled to find our
soul mate or whatever that means we're
all entitled to find our one so if
something goes wrong if a bunch of dates
and tinder swipes and matches go wrong I
bet that's really [ __ ] what's the
word like you can get really
disenchanted or like really like I'm
like I'm butchering this disenfranchised
but I feel like that can really messy
what mentally into thinking like well
he's good enough you know why not me you
know and in that taxi moment get real I
know when I was in college yeah I was in
a I had like generalized anxiety
disorder and probably depression I don't
but I was super super in a dark place
and the thing that cured me was getting
into this relationship with ela where I
had someone to confide in and when I was
having really troubled dark times I
could tell her and talk to her about it
and like having that release of emotion
you know I think is what really got me
out of that rut you guys ever done
therapy I actually have not yeah I'm
done Jack have you every I mean but I'm
sure it's a good on no but therapy's
worth it yeah worth it it well because
like well who the [ __ ] cares what this
person thinks of you you're paying them
right you get to say whatever you want
and and I think that when you put those
kinds of words in front of you you can
see them for what they are and you can
see that they really are just your
imagination in a lot of cases getting
the better of you and and that's the
worst part about depression and these
suicidal thoughts you're being tricked
into thinking this you're not your mind
is like you're that I'm feeling that way
but you know you're tricking yourself
into thinking people who kill themselves
I've heard often are afraid that they're
a burden on their friends and family and
that's why they do it which is never the
case it's not the case but it's that
mental illness a mental illness mental
illness is is a wild person by person
dragon that is ferocious and eat you up
from the inside and it's tough to put
words to it and I think that's why a lot
of people sort of just go it [ __ ] it and
and do themselves well it's sick because
you become your own worst enemy it's
like you're the one that's making
yourself suffer and it's just like you
begin to hate yourself yeah it's like
what the [ __ ] am i doing to myself yeah
I mean hey I smoked cigarettes so I'm
basically just slowly killing myself and
you know I don't know whoa now I'm gonna
drop that one oh [ __ ] I can't I can't I
can't compare that to what people with
depression feel like you know is knowing
that there's no
comparison there it's a terrible beast
then you need to talk to somebody yeah
therapist if you're impressed don't have
dark thoughts therapy it's not a
shameful thing my mom wanted it : hey
mom you're on there hi well you know you
guys were talking about suicide and I
wanted to chime in because I had a
personal experience when I was pregnant
I had thyroid cancer no once it was
removed they put you on synthroid which
is a synthetic thyroid medication that
you take to keep you balanced and a lot
of people that are suicidal it's a
chemical imbalance what happened to me
is after I had my surgery I had no more
thyroid tissue and the amount of thyroid
that I was taking before was not enough
and I woke up one morning and I thought
if this is what life's all about
I I can't I can't live and I thought to
myself this is crazy I just had a baby I
should have everything to live for
and so I called the doctor and they
changed my thyroid medication they upped
it by a lot and it was almost like
someone turning on a switch it was go
ahead what were you gonna ask oh no he
just said jeez yeah it was it was insane
I was literally thinking about how I was
going to take my life yeah and then and
then I realized this is crazy this
should not be happening and that's what
I called so you actually had like on the
side of bottles sometimes they say
symptoms side effects may include
suicidal thoughts no no no well maybe in
my case it wasn't a symptom it wasn't
enough thyroid because your pituitary in
your thyroid gland are your two major
glands and when you don't get enough of
that particular chemical your body is
lacking whatever it needs and
you know it can it can make you lucky so
in your case you had quite literal
chemical imbalance that's right and dad
and I actually had a friend who just got
married she had a chemical imbalance two
months after she was married she
committed suicide
that's so having a chemical imbalance is
very real
you know I'm sure there's there's so
many it's irrational
right the the desire to take your own
life is an irrational one it's yeah it's
well like I was feeling that why am i
living if this is what life is about
I I don't care to live it what was it
I'm actually just curious again inside
your head like what was it that was so
compelling about that thought and I felt
useless and I felt like I had no purpose
and I just felt a huge void and I didn't
understand it and I just thought if this
is what life is I really don't want to
live it yeah yeah yikes is right the
process of fixing yes so for someone who
just has a chemical imbalance you know
they might just check out right you know
so there's Kim you know I'm so glad now
the way that the insurance is with the
Affordable Care Act that mental problems
is considered just the way you know
someone like with a broken arm you know
it's very real what before it wasn't you
know a lot of people didn't get they
didn't get the care they needed but it's
a very real situation so I just thought
I'd come to your conversation thanks mom
yeah thank you
yes that's and how are you feeling no
mrs. clay how are you feeling now okay
she's alright she's good that's good
thanks mom
that is enlightening no that's great
yeah when you hear the phrase chemical
imbalance or at least like me personally
when I hear the phrase chemical
imbalance I don't think much of it I'm
not actually thinking it's a literal
imbalance like it's a physical
manifestation that can be righted I like
that's incredible your brain can I do
not know that my mom that's crazy my god
it's it's a great anecdote because she
actually like the three of us don't know
what the [ __ ] were talking about why
should we are in no way trying to solve
the problem or anything like that we
curate suicide simply our hot takes
based on yeah percentages and everything
yeah but to hear from somebody who's
actually had a chemical imbalance who's
gone through those issues that's it
tells you a lot because I mean now she's
she's happy she has you to look for and
hey at the very least right she has you
to live for it right damn that's I mean
yeah so it seemed I bet a lot of times
suicide comes from it's just super
irrational yeah it's hard to it's it's
weird to think that your thoughts in
your mood and how you see the world
the lens is is not even really kind of
out of your control
grebs yeah our brains are far that
[ __ ] fragile man like God when you're
four years old you could get any kind of
phobia / fetish / stalking from anything
anything for life as an adult you could
spend the rest of your life peeing with
your pants around your ankles yeah this
is something but not well I've seen yeah
yeah um yeah I'm afraid of balloons you
know what I mean and yeah it like I'm
guessing that it didn't just go from
zero to fixed that's been a situation
she said it was like a turn to light on
yeah but something yeah but but then it
was it yeah she mentioned and they
corrected it you gotta say something
yeah you have to say so that's the
biggest thing if you want those dark
thoughts if you have all that
talk about it you have to talking about
there so would it be a manifestation
yeah the [ __ ] face for know it's you
and me getting start from there it's a
really symbolic thing of getting it out
of your body yeah yeah absolutely the
thing Mike is it working life [ __ ]
sake Sarah okay we're good
I was just gonna say when I got hit the
hardest with my anxiety I held I was
like oh I'll tell you what I was
thinking at the time what didn't want to
let my fan
I thought I was going schizophrenic yeah
I didn't want to let my family down and
I was afraid just by saying it I was
making it real and so I held on to it
just hoping that it would get better for
like a month and I kept getting worse
and worse and worse to the point was
like almost certain that I was fully
schizophrenic and I only got better the
point where I started actually talking
about it to my parents yeah yeah I don't
know and I think that's really the
takeaway if anyone's out there feeling
having some rough times I think
communication you know if you don't have
someone that you can talk to and in in
in your life go to a therapist and at
the very least there's suicide hotlines
that are free those are people who care
and they want you can talk to be on hold
like their job is to you're not some
[ __ ] like special case for them no
they're used to talking to people with
these projects there's a lot there's the
negative stigma still like I mean as
internal it's a great week yeah weeks
you know it's not it's it's a it's
something that you need to it's out of
your control nine times out of ten you
need to put a face on it you need to
figure out why it's happening so what
happen twenty what happen when you talk
to your parents about it well it was
like the beginning I mean it was a long
road but like I talked to my parents and
I I didn't get therapy but I went to a
psychiatrist just to like get a
diagnosis and she's like you're not
schizophrenic okay and I was like that's
a relief right right and I would I was
literally like three days away from
going to college so I didn't even have
time to get treated but she's like
you're not schizophrenic
probably have generalized anxiety
disorder she recommend getting a
therapist there I didn't do it I don't
know why and it was just really a matter
of time and then I think the the real
turning point was when I had this
trusting relationship with the other
where I could talk to someone about it
you know what's our like art you know
that yeah whatever yeah it's the it's
the skeleton of what happened there
though it can be applied to anyone
anyone who's having dark thoughts talk
to somebody
yeah so the you know if you're gonna if
you're gonna go down that road talking
to somebody what's the harm no [ __ ]
arm if you're a long way here's the
thing here's my the way I was thinking
at the time if you're so bad that you're
actually thinking about killing yourself
what do you have to lose by trying
anything at that point
yes yeah yes that's great way to put it
like you think Abraham Lincoln ever
thought about killing himself maybe I
actually I read that he was extremely
depressed person really really that true
yes
all right hey man that guy's on our
[ __ ] big currency hey how about that
movie it I haven't seen it yet I'm gonna
take a leak actually so I'll be right
back I'm too much of a [ __ ] to see I
can't it was actually not that scary
really it was just a really good movie
really yeah
that's what I liked that was in the book
it wasn't the book but I think they left
it out of both the miniseries and the
2017 movie all right here's the thing I
have to pee - should we take a break oh
man make that three all right guys we're
gonna go [ __ ] urinate we'll be back
in Asia together two minutes god bless
you
don't leave something terrible will
happen to you and your family guys how
many lives did we save today oh my god
it's fine great to my head to mine we're
saviors and saints and if the Pope shits
at his goddamn hat I fart in a blanket
I'm just sayin I'm gonna update my
Twitter bio to on September 15 saved
saved thousands Jesus saved yeah if
Jesus saved then I'm Jesus
good well put the morphine boost we'd
have even more population
here's what I love about you guys try
poofing today can I tell you what I love
about you guys yeah go for it sometimes
I have guests on here and it's like so
hard to have a conversation like I'll
shoot something to them and I get like a
one-sentence answer I'm like all right
I've gotta fix it I'm I've like and but
you guys I mentioned suicide and we're
[ __ ] launched off for 30 minutes it's
a beautiful thing
no we love to blow v8 right this is
exactly what I'm talking about
try saying that to locate all day [ __ ]
when I back to that related to booth in
at all yeah my ass yeah okay
so by a long-ass time ago I made this
this video I did like I used to do a
series called your grammar sucks so for
like the hundredth we don't know about
that why did you I don't want to like
like start and be like you you're like
but like I don't why I still for the
hundred what do you mean used to I'm
trying to bring it back what's that next
one coming out yeah yeah yeah as soon
but for the hundredth episode it was
like feature-length it was like an hour
long so this is so honestly all to fill
that time I had to shoot with everyone
that was anyone you know like I did
everyone and for forever reason I never
hit up you guys because I don't think I
knew of you guys back then but I mean
like you know if I were making it now of
course yeah oh well that there's that
too um we were but uh oh oh yeah you're
notorious stay in the shadows ya know
but like I bring it up because I'm like
so you talked about like guests that
were like hard to really save more than
a sentence that happened to me a lot so
like there are some guys you know Eric
pops on we shoot for like three hours
and we're just drinking just shooting
the [ __ ] and I love the videos you guys
made together
oh we have so much fun I tend to forget
the cameras on right right yeah and yeah
and then there are the guys there are
all these pretty boy youtubers that I
collaborate with and your grammar sucks
100 and they they one word answers that
I'm trying to like make small chat so
I'm setting up the cameras I'm setting
up the camera and the lights and I'm
trying to like make him feel at home you
know before we get into like you know
work mode and they're not giving me
nothing
they're not giving me help be
help you thank you and it's impossible
help me I'm not looking for one a this
is a podcast we're having a conversation
again toss me a [ __ ] don't toss me
about like like this is only as much fun
as you make it right so I can relate to
your two guests that you may have had
that just don't know how to carry
conversation could I blame up yes am I
gonna keep suicide stats I'll disagree
the whole time yes yes no dark I just
want to remind everyone how anyway we
were talking about it let's take a shot
let's take this to us this this episode
ends when we're basically passed out
yeah we're all gonna be in the stairs no
and here so this is long right thank you
this all goes as long as you guys are
willing to to hang through this to an
end to now turn it on turn it off mmm
tuck it in and have a laugh have a goof
have his videos I think that was George
Carlin's stand off you know turn into an
off I would you have a bit away
can we take note of just how much of
this we've had pretty good not even a
bottles worth so we got always cheers
boys cheers to to twitch to the h3
podcast a school hey to talking to
people in my right hey nothing wrong
look at humans are we're social
creatures whether you like it or not we
really really are we are evolved by
society and community yet and it's in
our [ __ ] DNA you gotta talk you gotta
talk I love that that's why that's why
the internet is so popular became
avoided anti sits a platform for
antisocial people so talk anti-social
extrovert as Kendrick Lamar says hold on
intra antisocial extrovert that's okay
crime okay I like that I guess could be
both you could be everything works well
the internet you can't I find myself on
the internet sometimes I'm extremely
social yeah I go to a party I'll [ __ ]
lurk in the corner not say [ __ ] to
anyone yeah but she can't make it a
[ __ ] karaoke tomorrow night so that's
cool
oh that's right and now I can yeah can't
make it this [ __ ] guy can mom a
girl's gonna be a party it's tomorrow
it's yeah it's my that already happened
yeah I can't make it
yeah if by the way I mean I meant the
putting on the on the spot earlier but
uh Adam from your movie sucks is in town
in November always is I really wanted to
go to The Price is Right
wait wait how does that work he has like
a ticket and it's free right this fruit
yeah you just sign up yeah
but that is yet you have to get in line
like sucks but how come is guaranteed go
together we can guarantee go together if
we all just go together but yeah I'm
Hank green you go call up call up your
boys and be like hey we're coming in
true for flying in hot drew hey it's
it's Ethan this is Ethan does Ethan
we're flying in hot how many followers
does the price is right Twitter account
half that's all I'm saying not more than
all of us combined probably that's what
I'm so more maybe maybe they have more
let's find out card let's do it no don't
[ __ ] crazy fun it's a crisis right if
you're watching right now we're coming
for you know if I'm coming [ __ ] up - the
price is right shouted sure Carrie and
shout to Bob Barker price is right on
Twitter has 210 thousand followers are
you [ __ ] kidding message losers hey
have your pets spayed or neutered all
right I love that know you Brandon
they're such a random shout-out I got to
say out of all the causes in the world
right that's the one that you go for it
I mean I like animals but goddamn I'd
like to pull the audience right now to
see if they really feel like they're
hanging out with us or if they're just
watching three adults get wait probably
the let I mean it's a healthy mix um
what's true well sometimes fat guys get
skinny and it's weird yeah no I think he
looks normal now like it was it was to
see the
immediate you still weirded out by
absolutely Jax like [ __ ] that skin with
whose line and I watch the occasional
episode a sitcom right you know he's
joking he's joke he's the fat jolly man
not be jovial I know then yeah but he's
got that skinny tall mic now and
remember that mic used to be really fat
no but I'm sure this looks great but I'm
sure it was always like the this like
that was the thing in the 70s too if you
ever watched the Game Show Network every
like you know sleazy looking game show
host Adam like you know like they're
holding it down here right somehow the
mic would be long and thin gonna give my
guests a little kiss like that guy who
always like Christie Steve Harvey no
Harvey definitely kisses the contestant
you can't say that on television you
know that man yeah I know that mean how
about Bill huh how about that guy could
break a couple people Marad we're on a
[ __ ] thank you thank you thank you
guys
pity laugh I'll take my dad he does that
and and we have a what's up chat group
with my whole family uh-huh and when
he's just like the king of dead jokes
really bad jokes and whenever he drops a
dad joke and somebody says Amol he
always says thank you like written out
thank you why that's even better thank
you that makes me so happy that's what I
have to look forward we're gonna win a
[ __ ] Streamy with this podcast right
can we please get some string babies
Emmys you I don't want any awards you
can't say that on television Peters no
no backing up on the streamys correct me
if I mean if I'm incorrect which I'm not
but you had some choice words on Twitter
oh yeah about 3 mese do you want to go
in on that or not I respect you if you
die I understand we got nominated for a
comedy well I actually want what I said
was like any awards because online they
always have these awards it's such a
scam where they're like you're nominated
right today and you have to beg your
fans to come spam our website with votes
and therefore increase our profile and
ad revenues so that we could market to
brands and get Adsense it's not a real
vote you don't have an academy you don't
have a group of people who decides
amongst themselves it's yeah any awards
show that leaves it up to a fan vote is
a total freaking scam especially online
I think all award shows are [ __ ]
horseshit
in the first place but I agree at least
history to the judges right if you have
ten people who collectively say this
guy's wins an award in comedy versus who
can who can beg most shamelessly on
Twitter like I remember a thewe see - a
couple years ago was not for like show
of the year and he he was so shameless
in his plugging and he won by the way
and he's like he was doing giveaways
where if you vote for me after the
giveaway and it's like dude you didn't
really win that award you just have no
shame yeah are you dissing on my man
phousi yes did you know he's like the
Muhammad Ali of tuna and the two pocket
and the Gandhi and the Malcolm X of the
Internet he's basically according to his
boots his way across YouTube like no
one's ever booth before and if there was
ever a pope had to [ __ ] in he's [ __ ]
shat now if the Emmys are like some sort
of like gross anus of like self padding
on the back right the the any of that
[ __ ] you're describing is like a
prolapsed anus grow all fully see the
whole thing oh well you just have to beg
for it alright that's how it works you
ever seen a sea cucumber it's like that
yeah it's like those things you get the
gift shops at the Smithsonian where like
it's like a woman in it and you say this
would make a really good fleshlight yeah
I never thought that as a kid as I
couldn't get boners yet that was as soon
as as soon as I get boners I look back
on those things like my dick in one of
those but my first thought because I
never had money as a kid my chance to
get money like seven bucks night but my
first thought was always like I would
like to put my dick in this yeah god
yeah I could luck this I could [ __ ] it
I could [ __ ] I would think that about
the the Triceratops Kyle
and well about that's your how you swing
that way where where would it go I'm
sorry
where'd it go into try sir life finds a
way hole somewhere where you [ __ ] it
well anyway about this dream he's
apparently the only ones that are up to
fan voting is like to so the comedy one
is actually up to some [ __ ] dudes in
a small room congratulations jerk off
into each other's face but but you got
nominated judges yes well
congratulations you should take it right
in there thank you I mean hey chances
are you guys are gonna win no I think
lies a woman cuz I wanna Liza Co she I
think she's gonna know I think she
deserves it I I don't know I can't say
well I know every but I haven't seen her
stuff I just like you guys so yes if you
are ace you know it's you or no let me
tell you if you were at [ __ ] squishy
joined this myth Sony and I put my dick
in you I know I know
and you tell that's why we're here mmm
he'll is gone will be you're a prison
mate take it out inside out on the scale
of time of Vonnegut falling downstairs
at 92 years old we are a couple stairs
down from you I think this is the most
and Bonica has been referenced in
especially his death he lived as he died
yeah tumbling tumbling tumbling nice
nice that's beautiful
it really tumbled into those wonderfully
worded tales
yeah he sure did he cut his way through
World War two uh-huh
he tumbled his way through life yep and
he tumbled his way right down those
stairs day after life and then legend
has it he's still tumbling to this day a
poetic humble house five miles
wow wow you really shoehorn that this is
sponsored by audible.com actually not
but
I feel like I might have turned some
sponsors off to my show just by making
have like loop box or loot crate
whatever the [ __ ] is going to work with
them but it's like yeah it's a very
specific box of [ __ ] yeah I mean that's
not a bad thing I thought is this [ __ ]
all the time
look it's objectively a boxer yeah I get
boxes of [ __ ] in the mail constantly
though I'm getting a giant Enter key in
the mail any day now
Oh from yeah yeah where you mash it and
it still plugs Lewis beep what are we
talking about it's like a big pillow yes
sounds like an enter button it's not a
wedding gift yes I read it quoted or
whatever the [ __ ] how it works on reddit
where you type you slash comment ticket
and one of the sub reddits that was like
I need it yeah yeah yeah you're like
it's a giant enter button that that is
not a box of [ __ ] though it is that
being said loot crate great people great
great people
hey hey great they want to sponsor me
again yeah that would be though I'll
take money let me say guys I miss loot
crate any anytime like a call from Grace
and grace and talk to me up grace tell
me what's good who are you what are you
doing where are you going with life
speak to me tell me what's good I can't
hear them oh there you are there you are
so first just really quickly before my
question going back a little bit Ethan I
just wanted to say I found you in ela
this summer right after a really hard
event in my life and to really laugh
again after that was one of the best
things anyone could give me during that
time so I wouldn't say that all those
kinds of messages you should take with a
grain of salt because trust me like it
was it was so refreshing to laugh again
that's one that's really nice thank you
for saying that I think it's mostly just
a self-defense mechanism of me being
like I don't want to feel I'm afraid of
getting it to my head and being like I'm
a [ __ ] Saint right
I really appreciate that thanks for
saying that yeah yeah um and so my
question and I'm sorry to get serious
again all right so I really related with
your story about your struggle with
anxiety before you met Ella and I was
wondering how you got to where you are
today and how to cope with your anxiety
now okay thanks for the question and the
really nice comments appreciate it I
think that like with depression anxiety
there's always a road to recovery
yes but it's often long and it is
challenging you know and this in like
the world we live in everybody's looking
for quick fixes I'll take some that
actually have a beer I was looking for a
quick fix right yes
yeah take a pill and you're like oh my
god like my mom said how she took a pill
on the light switch right like that's
what we all dream of happening roses
it's off it's a journey and for me like
it started when I was I was smoked I I
don't like smoking weed in high school
and my friends were smoking weed and so
I felt like oh I'm gonna smoke weed yeah
hmm and for me
for some people it's great some people
it doesn't work I was one of the people
I was really confident in high school
and I smoked weed and I smoked weed and
smoke weed and to the point where I felt
so alienated for myself and so confused
and so unhappy with the person I became
that this anxiety started building up
and one day it broke like a floodgate
and I had like this full-on panic attack
and it took me years to even understand
what happened it's a real long journey
you have to be willing to kind of face
your demons you know take a little good
look a good hard honest look at yourself
and understand like why like what's the
root of this right what the [ __ ] is
actually going on and confront this and
I think part of doing it's it's all it's
almost impossible to do by yourself
the
you have all these thoughts and all
these negative emotions circling in your
head you have no perspective on it
everything when I was in my most anxious
every small thing that I had ever done
in my past every little thing became a
[ __ ] mountain of of like guilt and
depression and it was just like I felt
impossible to overcome but it's not
until you can start communicating that
and and working through that with an
external source which in my case was ela
someone who had trusted someone who I
could talk to without judging me and who
could had like a unconditional love for
me that I was able to confront those and
work through it externally because in
your mind you can't really look at it
logically and objectively because
everything feels so real and intense and
so it's like every time first of all I
would tell her about it and just say
like hey this is part of who I am and
what I'm going through okay so that's
part of it and then I'd have good days
and bad days when I'm having bad days I
would say hey I'm having a bad day this
is why and I would talk about and I'll
get it out and it's really just this
whole thing of getting it out right and
and thinking about it externally because
you got it you have to get it out of
your body I thought about it's like you
have to let it evaporate in a way it's
like a pool of [ __ ] negative sludge
because it builds up yeah you got to let
it evaporate you got to let it kind of
float how do you and like gasoline
right yeah yes it needs an outlet it can
evaporate it needs Heat any sunshine ela
was my sunshine but it's a metaphor but
I think it's enough you need that extra
energy you need something that's gonna
stimulate it and and and stimulate that
evaporation yeah yeah what's up was that
quick in the process as catalyst right
thank you that's it that's exactly now
not everybody's lucky enough to have
someone like eel in their life and if
there are outs there are like even yes
there's that person there are always
there's always mediums to get
like you know know like what if it's
drawing you know or anything you know
like any talent or popular just
something there's always an outlet there
is you need an outlet you know if you
don't have some like Ella you get a
therapist right you find someone I
thought there's always there's a lot of
great people out there with good kind
hearts who want to see you get better if
it's someone on the other end of a
suicide hotline therapist it's their
[ __ ] profession for Christ's sake
yeah there's no shame and going and
talking to a therapist because they do
genuinely care about you
the only thing is they got to make a
living I do feel like it's that therapy
in itself has become less and less of a
stigma it's just awesome
more people are just it's just become
more socially accepted I think everyone
should have a therapist even if you're a
completely normal human being she stole
if you can it out [ __ ] go to a
therapist talk to them about
I think matter what you've got problems
everybody everywhere bust everyone's
following are no exceptions normal is
you can't look at the world and go
everybody's perfect but on man but it's
wrong and shy you tell yourself that
would be a fallacy it would be a policy
it's probably what a lot of people think
- yeah that's right that's what gets
people dug into these trenches of like
self-pity and horrible feelings is like
you're like everyone else is normal they
got their [ __ ] together why don't ya
there's no such thing as normal we're
all in saying normals like this this
idea we have in our head of what you're
supposed to feel like or how I used to
feel I feel like twelve should be a
really dangerous place because everyone
almost always wants to tweet about their
accomplishments and their highs and
their happy moments and when you see
enough of that you get a case of like
FOMO if you're missing out and you get a
case of like man that guy's life is
perfect what am I doing wrong nothing
he's just leaving out all the bad [ __ ]
you don't see that on Twitter yeah
yeah they write it into their stuff
creatively yeah like you look at a
pretty much any goddamn TV show and
you're watching the yeah the
inadequacies and
the failings of the person who's
responsible for it playing before you
but through other people's mouths all
right I say these people are completely
[ __ ] up right yeah right like American
Horror Story with guy Ryan Murphy yeah
that guy's got to be [ __ ] where the hell
do you think that's coming from so I
don't know I think you just gotta lie
guys we said earlier if you're if it's
so bad that you're like I'm gonna [ __ ]
and kill myself well take that and let
it feed your your desire to get help
because if it's that bad you got nothing
to lose nothing to lose
go for it you know what it you can only
go up right I mean it's rock bottom from
there so go up and and and if you're
that deep and dark like you said you
have only better days ahead
yeah by by continuing giving shots you
know your potential for happiness and
betterment becomes zero if you take that
route so by not like the classic sinks
is you know time heals all wounds and to
an extent I do I do believe that yeah
like especially if you're young yeah oh
yeah when you're when you're like when
you're in high school and even college I
remember the the jokes I made in high
school I remember the friends I had in
high school I remember weird [ __ ] that I
saw like and but when I think about it
back towards then like I also remember
the things that like stressed me out
sure the things that I worried about
they're nothing it's yes it's nothing
yeah
high school is a nothingness absolutely
if if you fall into that you just got to
remind yourself that college is next and
that's when you really get to get
[ __ ] know yourself no I mean besides
the dick way like that's that's where I
found like high school is my nice long
awkward phase I was in marching band and
you know I didn't get a lot of slizz in
marching band true story can
believe it but it was it wasn't until
the hollows where I found myself and
like college is where I realized what I
wanted to do and that's where I made
friends and I'm still friends with to
this day that I'm inviting to the
wedding you know because that's and
that's not to say that that's gonna be
the case for everyone know there are a
lot of people are way closer to their
highschool friends and their college
friends or its d50 and for me it's it's
all college but like there's all there's
going to be a time where you really find
yourself whether it's high school or
college or before or beyond or even in
your 30s or 40s there's no limit there's
no limit you really seek out most famous
comedian out there yeah dude never even
had his break until his 40s that's
pretty cool he was nobody pretty much
until his [ __ ] forties but the whole
time he was trying he never gave up
right right
you know that's inspiring [ __ ] I'm just
saying and through what a divorce had a
kid yeah am I right or am I just I'm
assuming there was a divorce and a kid
in there there's a divorce there's a kid
yeah like I don't know yeah it's awesome
it's never too late yeah I got another
call for Pete's matter epochal ex nice
hey apocalypse talk to me tell me what's
good how are you apocalypse hey what's
going on what's going on Jack and Eric
yeah I got a crazy one for you guys so
you were I think Ethan couple episodes
ago he was talking about how he wants to
believe an extraterrestrial entity it's
going back to conspiracy stuff okay okay
yeah yeah yeah this is for you Eric
I want to talk to you about Project Blue
Book you know the United States Blue
Beam blue book blue book okay Air Force
compiled 22,000 UFO reports from the end
of war to to the late 50s and they
they've since closed the operation
but 700 reports still remain
unidentified today so I want to know if
that's enough evidence for you Ethan I
think that's pretty astounding how you
know the UH the US Air Force man they're
they're all over UFOs and they did that
once
well I got a question for him man yeah
go ahead hey where do you think these
[ __ ] aliens are coming from dude you
know when you think about it spaces you
know almost quite literally endless so
dude who knows no do you maybe well
maybe it's the center of the earth you
know there's the Antartica conspiracies
what if you were to guess like just use
your imagination what do you think that
their home planet society looks like
that they're out here investigating us
what's their what's their purpose yeah
what why what's under Janis said was
that it's like Star Trek like right you
know do you think it's a piece of junk
oh it's a peaceful mission man yeah I
think it's observance honestly we're
kind of like a petri dish in a lab man
we're just we're just uh an out here
flown around on our little earth man
they're they're like the UM what are you
called like the the Master Hand or
whatever you want to call it so your
question for me essentially is well I
you're asking me is this certain amount
of sightings enough for me to believe
well yeah no it's not enough because
you're just one dude telling me that I
would need to see it not true picking
that up but like like even I'm what I
what I my thing is like an official
source like the US government US Air
Force they're investigating into this
they actually took their time and money
to investigate into UFOs so how is it
they does that not enough proof you know
well I recall them doing that they did
that in like the 80s or something when
there was like a whole hysteria about
UFOs yeah and I know their official
conclusion was that there was nothing
yet but you don't buy that no no not at
all I'll have to look I'll have to have
to look deeper have you ever had an
experience with UFO I have actually tell
us buddy
hell yeah okay this was
god this is probably five years ago just
on a little farm road and I live on
Bonilla so you know kind of out in the
middle of nowhere I'm Road every goddamn
yes help me find me my dad were just
driving around we were going somewhere
and we saw something fly over the car it
looked like a balloon and we couldn't
really get a good glimpse of it until it
was flying off
it was amazing speed I don't know what
it was
could have been a balloon but it man
that thing took off into the clouds and
I it just disappeared
it was going faster than any I've ever
seen but you know what about I believe
you I totally believe no I'm just so
scared that I'm a horse like this
because I've never seen a video I've
never it's never happened to me you
think I want some [ __ ] proof you know
like I trust you but you're but like as
Carl Sagan famously said extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
oh yeah I know you're saying like I know
you're kind of like under the seeing is
believing but we need people like you to
tell us what you've seen so that we can
acquire the evidence necessary all right
thanks Doug thanks for your question
appreciate you yeah see you guys take
care of dougie thanks dog bye man that
guy sounds like he's got a big dick Oh
clearly so we're they doing on that farm
rug so wait a minute like is that proof
I mean no I don't take anecdotes as
proof I trust them I believe them what
can I do I can't stretch my imaginary
saying I love it's not that can't be
proof like but it's not enough for me
like oh yeah UFOs exist because this
dude's using alien life waitis no 100%
it's almost impossible that there aren't
[ __ ] life-forms somewhere in the
universe I guess you can't like use his
Li like you can't disprove that theory
just on his anecdote that's all I'm
saying no yeah yeah no I can't okay
at Carl Sagan said it best extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
this is an anecdote by one dude who I
has no reason to lie on I believe
he's experiences genuine well it's not I
can't just say oh yeah I believe in UFOs
oh yeah I mean I love the idea I love it
of UFO I want it's so [ __ ] fast
lighting just out here I think that
we're probably on the same page as that
guy was like you know some crazy [ __ ]
out there oh who the [ __ ] knows like who
you know the first person to see a b-52
bomber what the [ __ ] do you think they
thought that looks pretty alien yeah but
with the jagged yeah those things are
crazy looking and I wouldn't put it past
if there was an alien race out there
that was actually observing us there
every now and then they'd [ __ ] up get
shown yeah especially on a farm Road I
mean look aliens are in our galactic
interstellar I don't receive many
slip-ups
look all we can really garner from that
call is that dude's got a big one he's
got a huge one got a gradual ations on
that yeah so hey thanks for the call
study and get some more calls in here
god damn it this is fun
well I'm gonna compliment every caller
oh yeah that was my plan from the
beginning oh she got a girl hey you got
a deep one no this whole no you gotta go
I don't know I was live so I'm gonna
bail on anything I think is gonna go
dark side tell ya
yeah Tony town Hey look I want to talk
about it the movie yeah I'll come I love
haven't seen the [ __ ] it wasn't scary
and that's the way of like you know you
see these I like that a lot and I hate
horror film so what did you what did you
like about it it was a great movie
super suspenseful not scary oh I like
that and when they were like scary it
was very self-aware it's ironic and it's
it's a whimsical in a way what now
there's a word I haven't heard
associated with the movie yeah yeah what
is it swims occult I hear I hear my boy
fin was was the [ __ ] is Richie yeah I
complimented him yeah yeah all the kids
were great yo show us great [ __ ] fin
like it's [ __ ] hilarious it's cool
I can't wait for stranger things season
two I
and I think is he coming on yeah you've
got to do it I want to get him in the
whole damn cast I kid sure oh my god you
could yeah you could pull off Wendy
when's that supposed to come as don't
know okay
hopefully they'll tell me when they come
on he he sent me a message on Twitter or
something like that it was like hey I
like your videos and I was like ah I
sent him a thing where I was like I just
watched stranger things I sent one back
and he sent me a message that was like
hello this is a representative for
stranger things we don't want 27 year
old alcoholics the promoter outdid me
right kids these days god damn it just
get off the damn internet you're way too
mature seriously anyway so it yeah in
the last scene of the movie it's not a
spoiler if they're like hey if the clown
ever comes back
we'll be here and they touch they cut
hands and they hold hands they make like
about blood promise yeah in the book I
read there's one girl who they all want
to [ __ ] and there's a lot of sexual
tension between them all in the movie as
well as the book and in the book they
these kids run trained on this little
girl they take turns [ __ ] this little
girl right so in the movie they all cut
hands and hold hands but in the book
they actually run train them in Stephen
King's mind it was her right and I was
like holy smokes that wasn't in the
movie yeah so that was kind of shocking
when I read that yeah he was on a lot of
coke when he wrote that yes I was gonna
say it though he liked the way he
defended it I'd uh how he said and he
said I found it in Turin
fascinating dare you say fascinating
that's a band board that people would be
so hung up on on the sex scene and not
as hung up
well the multiple child yeah let me
extras' that because I think it sounds a
weak point oh it's a book about child
murder oh yeah yeah it it's not
surprising when a kid gets murdered by a
killer Klown that's the whole premise of
the book it is surprising when a bunch
of 12 year olds run train on a girl this
is that horrifying Gary endo I mean yes
I've read a lot of studying and I think
that that is right up his alley like
keep but it was like a moment it was
moment of that yeah yeah weird like
they're up against a supernatural horror
right from the toe - they're the two -
whatever the hell it's called a
different universe right these beings
exist right and this thing [ __ ] like
crash-landed in what's the name of the
town Denny somewhere you know well
anyway wild imagination that's Stephen
King it's always the main inland and
Stephen King is incredible the guy has
written some of the but he's like the
Shakespeare for our time if I'm being
honest
the dude who wrote it and a childhood
orgy also wrote Shawshank Redemption
that is okay that's quite a regice
incredible yeah you can say sure if I
want to call him Shakespeare yet you
know I mean dude that guy has made his
own [ __ ] language out of things no
that guy has has permeated into our
popular culture like no one else since
Shakespeare he's really really he's got
that in his repertoire that haven't been
made in the movie the guy is here he's a
fortunate force of nature yeah
incidentally you know he also he likes I
mean kids they had run train home each
other they weren't trained so that's
fine yeah he he must have like I don't
know I I will defend that scene just off
of the basis that it was uncomfortable
and horrifying yeah in in the context of
what was going on what has to be
horrifying I guess I have you read the
book I have it yeah I haven't read it
recently I read it a long time ago okay
so I'll defer to you on that because I
haven't read it I just read about that
but it's a way for them to get out of a
situation which is not a defense in any
way but the fact is looking device
debate I don't think he wrote them into
a corner and then said how am I gonna
get them out of here Oh a [ __ ] yeah like
I think he was like what is the worst
thing that you can do to some kids well
I'd love to hear him say that instead of
defend it by saying well kids are
getting murdered I mean we got a treat
or was that like a response he gave on
the phone I think it was that tweet
there's a thing worse where David Lynch
is in an interview and he says
Eraserhead is is the most
what is it the MA [ __ ] I don't know that
the most personal I'm personal I'm
making them the most personal story I've
ever written and the interviewer is like
can you elaborate and he's like now
that's a good impression that is right
the weather today Cloudy with a Chance
of cigarette Cooper did you see the girl
with the red hair Cooper what the hell
every watch that man Cooper Cooper did
you watch the new twin peaks' not the
new one Game of Thrones really I was
more excited not disappointed with that
show not at all
all right your idea Neji knew exactly
that it was gonna do the second if
you've ever watched a David Lynch movie
yeah you know it ends like that and I'm
not gonna spoil what the ending is no
just but the second to like the second
to last episode I was like oh my god
that was super satisfied sure do we go
for me second last episode was follow
immediately by the last episode which
was super like oh it was it was a 2
episode night yes it was and he went
okay let me I'm gonna give you the the
episode that solves everything right
here's the one that [ __ ] you Cooper I'm
gonna give you the episode that solves
everything
he's death in the show so he talks he's
got them right amazing he's actually got
more lines than like anyone else so yeah
he's wanted to make carries a huge part
of it I know he was in the yeah so he's
like the lead investigator in the new
one
what yeah he's he's actually my favorite
character in the new one he's he was
amazing he was incredible yeah it's
worth watching I said it's worth the
watch no question I'm going to watch it
inevitably my question to you guys is
sure I saw the first two seasons when I
was in college some 10 years ago
10 7 and 10 years ago on DVD is it worth
do I have to would you recommend that I
read one no no I necessarily watch the
last commissary
now you don't it's it's it's a you're
good watch a youtube recap of last
episode I was like watch a five minute
recon I'm awful entertainment we go yeah
I listen the whole new show was kind of
like an impressionist painting of is
someone smearing their [ __ ] on a canvas
and you're like mm that's interesting
should watch fire walk with me though
because there's actually a lot of
callbacks to that yes fire walk with me
was a great movie on its own you think
right yeah that's a crazy movie about
like abuse and [ __ ] and it was only very
very loosely tied you you don't see coop
at all in the movie no but you see a
David Bowie's character who's important
in the show and yes and the new one
agent agent Jeffries picture that well
it's a voice puzzle that's together he's
a voice at any rate I love I love the
guy he's got great [ __ ] hair oh you
smoke their whole lives in stole yeah
keep it together
humbled the hilt um take a tumble at 92
let's not lose him to his [ __ ] set of
stairs oh I listen if I could they had
those stairs
I'd rather I'm tumbled to his oblivion
than like dying in a hospital bed slowly
of lung cancer yeah well I mean I feel
like his stem cells are in the bank hey
guys man here's something gross okay put
the camera on me ready
oh Jesus man suck on that the [ __ ] I
don't know just trying to give some
break guys you want to say you want to
do something gross either just vomits on
no come on
are you sick [ __ ] come on he's sick [ __ ]
[ __ ] your belly when you get out of
my face you freak
I flake that hard
I don't want to see your [ __ ] yeah I
don't actually do that I broke my hands
for this podcast something to share so a
child rape right back to the check can
we please get back let me let me put let
me show you guys something
yeah I've been sitting on this video
yeah you guys aren't psyched for Paul to
take her to a hotel for the night by
Bebo's sake rainy to a a hotel to stay
with me based on his facial expressions
this is definitely not going he's asking
this girl's parents if he can take her
to a hotel room go on dude yeah he flies
down to Brazil buys himself a bride and
then he'd go he got the balls to go to
her parents house and say hey can I take
your daughter to a hotel how about just
don't tell him don't tell him that
that's how your thing to say to your
your your girl's parents just take it
right yep but well hey some people dis
aren't you know say about social cues
this wouldn't work in Utah or actually
Utah's a bad example this wouldn't work
in asking hey can't take your daughter
it has sex with her and an inert
a motel or something that nature that
isn't what is that really I'm not
looking rushing anything like that right
now with greenie dude but II have a
client awesome
I haven't told Craney about any of that
hey can I take hikes morning love the
clips
why is he translating this one by the
way the girl obviously knows how to
translate what you're seeing wrong she
doesn't speak English and he doesn't
speak Portuguese or Spanish and
Portuguese in Brazil oh wait don't
communicate there's a bad matchup yeah
money I want to keep her honor look at
his face they're really jazzed these
parents are so jazz take it murdered I'd
murder him Jesus Christ that's that's
our cringe
that's your that's where I found it that
sounds real yeah good lord that's is
that how the kids in it got out of the
sore can I take your daughter to hotel
can I run trained on your dad does your
daughter baby I want to take your
daughter to hotel but keep her honor oh
my water what a [ __ ] mess TLC
uploaded that like oh they knew what
they were doing yeah they knew exactly
what this [ __ ] we don't care I'm a
hundred percent yeah all right Dan bring
in the news let's [ __ ] wrap this
[ __ ] of the great bring your dog
canoes well no we're not done but Dan's
gonna come do the news I thought we were
doing this until we pass out well keep
drinking cuz this news can last a while
alright what time is it it's oh my god
we've been going for three and a half
hours really no yeah holy [ __ ] it's time
for another shot of honey watching
anymore we could just do it well no
there's there's so 11,000 people
watching this nightmare air give me your
glass damn burger goddamn news
got some colors dad hold off don't come
in color I love the colors isn't it oh I
thought you meant like a shocked by the
way this caller feature is like my
favorite part of the show now I like it
it's nice it's so cool yeah they're
they're nice people that are calling in
three all right Carissa hello um
firstly before I asked a question it's
my brother's birthday tomorrow and he's
a big sanity Ethan what's beyond beyond
happy birthday dear Stella Australis
perchance uh yeah what time is it there
cool uh I'm late for work but it's 9:30
but it's worth it
Nathan I have a question for you okay um
how are you going since ale is gone do
you have anything planned this week now
that you buy I'll be doing okay thanks
for thinking of me it's rough I'm not
gonna lie my life is a dumpster fire
thank you so much something gone oh well
okay
meanie uh we've been married for four
years but we've been together for like
10 plus years and we have lived together
continuously for like seven years from
the moment she moved in to end with me
in Santa Cruz and since that time we
have never been separated so it's pretty
bizarre having her gone like it's only
been two days I'm not gonna lie it's
[ __ ] rough I am so dependent on her
it's kind of scary and [ __ ] up do you
mean me and Jack to come cook for you
I need ice you do you got any of those
Smithsonian sea slugs yeah Oh couple I
can make one with my hand well I can
work with that
just put some saran wrap on the
yeah come on how was this different it's
why I can work with it now but how do
you fill ours it's [ __ ] weird it's
really weird you know it's it's probably
a good thing that like we do it but it's
it's kind of just pathetic once I'll
dependent I am on her like I came to the
studio today I forgot the cameras had to
go back to the house always a whole hour
I don't know it's like you when you're
in so intimate and you're so tied up
with someone in your life they really
are like a limb and and I feel like I'm
missing a limb it's very you know it's
beautiful but also it makes you very
vulnerable but that yeah that's the
beauty of it I I can they take it's not
quite the same but I can kind of relate
when aaron has a long day at work you
know she doesn't come to long day of
work I know she's it so my thing out for
those no my fiance has an office job I'm
the you generate like you know sits at
home does my own [ __ ] and my fiance
aaron has an office job and like a
nine-to-five but sometimes you know she
goes long hours right and if she doesn't
come home so like eight or nine like I
don't know what to [ __ ] do with my
stuff yeah occasionally she'll go on a
business trip for a few nights
I don't know how like all of a sudden
it's 3:00 in the morning
and I don't know where the [ __ ] time
went right I didn't have dinner or
whatever because that's that's my rock
she's my rock
we like we're so used to like a limb
we're so used to doing stuff together
it's [ __ ] weird when we're apart so I
get I can [ __ ] relate to what you're
going through you ever seen this movie
stuck on you
with Matt Damon I didn't finish
I've seen trailers yeah so it's about
these Siamese twins they're attached
literally at the hip mm-hmm and it ends
I'm gonna suppose give this a [ __ ]
30-year old movie but it's great watch
it yeah they get it ends when they get
separated and they have like this crazy
separation anxiety and yeah it's like
yeah I don't know what to do because
she's like my thoughts my the way I
communicate the way I think the way it's
been my free time
is so wrapped up and always having her
with me yeah that it's really uh it's
really well you're a family unit
yes yeah absolutely and that's really
cool though I mean like that's two weeks
that's a good honestly that's what I
hate to say it's a good problem to have
you know because that's a beautiful
thing no I'm very fortunate and but what
you do is you do stuff that you couldn't
do with her so like my whatever what
that rebate if you're furious on Twitter
yeah I was gonna say watch like cheers
by the way Eric's Christmas this has
been the best week thank you so much I
forgot your name but thank you so much
for the question appreciate you so much
Karissa
Karissa Karissa for six lanes at all oh
wow shout out to that demographic that
gets it right
90s kids only Ferguson was that was that
the brother Ferg Ferguson Virg Virg
whatever was the guy who put the ladder
up in [ __ ] rapes are at 3:00 a.m. oh
yeah
sewer I think sort like a so it's a kid
banging each other it joke oh yeah yeah
anyway okay so Ted Cruz got caught
choking off the incest porn and then
[ __ ] shkreli that's it that's it that
mister should rally putting a bounty on
what Hillary's hair by the way lock of
her hair or something yes Eddie a lot of
people I've seen them complaining like
oh why would someone get thrown in
prison for making a joke well okay let's
break this down
yeah so score le was out basically on
the goodwill of this judge right who
said his bond at five million dollars
because he's a [ __ ] convicted criminal
I'm not judging the guy
he was convicted in a court of law he's
a convicted criminal that's the same in
effect okay matter of law it's a matter
of law I sit down nice nice and so the
dude is tweeting out even in jest it's a
little alarming to be like I will get
five thousand dollars to anyone who can
get me Hillary's hair and he entered
that same one with by saying not kidding
not right not joking not yeah and so I'm
not a one way or the other I'm not going
to leave that last part out you know not
kidding so I'm not saying one way or the
other you know I'm not passing judgment
I'm only saying I understand where the
judge was coming from because it only
takes a couple of lunatics to be like
I'm gonna grep I'm gonna get some of
that of her hair and there's a lot of
people who wish it on Hillary Clinton
and again I'm not judging anybody I'm
just stating facts so I I think it's
within the realm of understanding that
the judge would revoke his bond and say
you know what I don't want you out on
bond I want you in prison because you're
unfit you're dangerous to society that's
what she said I understand it I'm not
passing judgment on what right now right
right
his apology [ __ ] buddy what was his
apology I don't think well it's
obviously an apology that his lawyer
wrote that he just signed on the bottom
lawyer sucks yeah well I think they did
the best with what they had and that's
not the best okay it's the best yeah
he's kind of a dick certainly yeah I
wish I could call in right now so we
could ask them what terminating [ __ ]
questions how serendipitous would that
be Jesus Christ by the way yeah oh I
know I I'm sorry I went Oh Barbara
Walters on him by the way I didn't mean
to do that it just kind of happened but
long story short Merry Christmas
Eric this is the best week you left a
good week it's a really good week this
is a great way to end that week too yeah
I'm just hanging out with with some of
my best friends we're eating pizza we're
getting drunk there's a bunch of people
watching who are gonna post on the
subreddit after like hey you know what I
think
I hate Erick at least you have a loving
subreddit man that's you know good for
you good for you
well Eric probably you both you guys man
subreddits are great okay we have one on
standby drew from ninja yeah
Oh jeah fro nature talk to me baby
hello Ethan how's it going hey how are
you all right first of all I'm a huge
fan been a fan since taking the boom oh
it's a damn snake in the boot thanks
sucks my question is if bringing it back
to aliens here we go yeah if if all of
history was erased
except for 2017 and you guys had to
preserve one thing from 2017 to give to
the aliens what would it be
Wow holy so oh my god it Wow we got a
lot to chew on good luck thanks for the
question man it's actually a question
mark okay okay okay
one thing 2017 you know what okay so now
we got to go back Ted Cruz looking at
porn yeah it's pretty great that you
very great but that is just the most
recent one we got to think about all of
27 like what happened I'm thinking of
like well we have a sunbae meme but what
what salt Bay aliens have to do with
aliens by the way you made you made it
weird Ethan you made it
hey what was his name
flourishing his name was Clarissa fro
that's what his name what the [ __ ] that
have to do aliens leave [ __ ] Rick how
about how about other I'm tired of that
about just season three of Rick and
Morty and every time I burped that means
it's a good [ __ ] shrieking more Derek
so she dick I burped long before Rick
and Morty was on double vision Jeff
Rossen invented burping yeah he sure did
just the whirling also invented House of
Cosby's so what you referenced like
[ __ ] love that oh yes you do when I
was I met him yes yeah yes and his
response to it was goddamn brilliant and
his response he he got he made this
whole show that was actually a good show
right about a guy who
bill cosby bones him too many times and
it sort of follows the rules of
multiplicity where each clone has their
own quirk yeah and he got threatened by
Bill Cosby's legal team this is before
Bill Cosby we knew that he had rave
right he said women they sent him a
legal threat and their response was to
make like a way dumbed down version of
the show I think it was devoid of color
even he was black and white and it was
just like the stupidest version of the
show that they had already made possible
and like it looks like like fan art
almost of what they were making and it
turned into this [ __ ] night can I can I
ask you can I this is going a little
tangent but I died I've always been
curious how did you guys meet how did
you become friends
oh yeah topic of conversation because
they were no clue yeah it was really
quite a funny thing um psychic pebbles
Zak I know if you guys know him [ __ ] him
so I was friends with him in fact I was
working with him in New York on a
project with jontron and psychic pebbles
and it was right around the time we
posted our finebros video apparently
justin saw and he really liked it
but he was friends with Zach at the time
yeah and I was sitting next to Zach and
Justin texted Zach was like hey do you
know anything about h3h3 and he's like
yeh sitting right next to me huh it's
just really weird and so then I don't
know you
he gave me an error he gave Justin my
phone number and we're like hey dude
nice to meet you and that's so funny
anyway there's I didn't talk to him for
a long time and then I moved to LA yeah
and we're like hey let's hang out and
that was it cheese we just started
hanging out no he's one of them normal
dudes who also happens to be an absolute
comedic [ __ ] that's normal dude
that's so nice to hear because you want
like down-to-earth comedic geniuses are
hard to find well he also has like he's
like slightly he's extremely autistic
okay he has like autistic outbreaks are
gonna be hang out there be like mommy
put poop in my butt or some [ __ ] like
that he makes me love him more
I'm like Justin he has like these these
very endearing autistic outbreaks um
which I love him for he's a great guy
that's awesome okay so so shadow come
shout out the psychic penalties for like
really and making it possible basically
invented the phrase [ __ ] had come
buckets I love that phrase so that was
from him yeah I don't know that bevel is
an interesting dude yeah yeah I miss
that guy I haven't seen him in a while
he's in LA he's doing great good for him
I like his podcasts a lot it's just like
yeah yeah yes oh well I wouldn't I mean
I catch up on him he makes like one of
freakin three months exact I'm pissed
well he's a busy animator give him some
[ __ ] space Jesus Christ step it up
Zack Wow now were they friends let's go
to his [ __ ] subreddit openness give
me more help and I wasn't happy with the
way that the blog
sigh we derailed so hardcore I apologize
yeah my favorite moment of 2017 was this
podcast Wow way to remember I I didn't
even remember the yeah what was our look
what did if every other year was erased
and we only end when he said [ __ ] what
else happened in 2017 god damn it oh
right not a great year then I took a
bite vodka you missed although you got
only the cheese on my pizza in the shot
glass oh yeah oh thanks for reminding me
that we still have shots today that's
good
I just finished mine mmm that's yours so
here's one 2017 we would we would send
alien what's like a decent YouTube video
what made the sending right is that what
the question what I mean history of the
world I didn't catch that by that guy
butter me like yeah we can do better
I would definitely send Ted Cruz jacking
off the end point there's got to be
something better but I can't think of
anything it's not depressing it's like
we can't boil down 2017 to like a decent
meal or a decent and yeah it'd be on Ted
Cruz jacking off I don't know what's
happened in the year until the end of
the year exactly NN tells me
what's happened in the air or YouTube we
have every day bro no no you movie
that's you you can really that's my
stick but no yeah we can do better we
know better I don't know what youtuber
really like blew up this year that like
I just not that I want to give him a
[ __ ] youtuber I'm just trying to like
go off like I want to legit answer this
question I don't think I'm going to but
I mean it's the Hennessy talking at this
point beau this is this is the year of
Donald Trump isn't it yeah it was one
moment you could crystal exactly there's
there been so many and oh my Lillian
Apple is getting banned from Twitter
it's not all bad we got this [ __ ]
freak out of there all right yeah bring
on the news let's wrap this oh my god I
love it
speaking of child orgies right I'm
talking about the Joe Rogan no I just
know that guy got [ __ ] as a kid way
too many times and he's cool with it
well it was the predator going after the
priest right right
learn to blow people from a young age Oh
Milo I think men show Rogan no no Joe
Rogan just grills elk meat about that
okay news his whole Instagram is just
helped me already yeah yeah here's what
I cooked today when I was in elk
I wonder what Joe Rogan ahead for lunch
today I bet you can find out it's
probably what oh yeah yeah okay we got
send in the nudes do you want some Lynn
Lynn pubes okay I snorted some in the
bathroom it was a fantasy I saw yeah I
took it back out
is anyone else excited for Christmas as
I am because Christmas is my favorite
time of year since can I see this and I
get real horny that's an order excited
you know drilled in at the top give it a
sniff I love your eagerness to submit
you [ __ ] the first time you were really
heavy
you really get your nose it's actually
not that bad I'll be honest I like I
don't know it's so musty
it smells like unwashed laundry for
months it does but it's like it's it
doesn't smell like Bo you know what I
mean it's cozy picture you're really
grossed out by that it's such a strong
did you ever smell this damn yeah wow
what a trooper thank you it's musk not a
good one I can tell the cleaning
products uses the problem what do you
see you can tell me have for Brett he's
his Irish Spring soap I remember that
[ __ ] right hell yeah I definitely her
spring soap he wears Hanes Oh
give me the [ __ ] comfort soft hey I'm
JJ I'm plugging this up all right I'm
putting this away we're at 11,000
viewers right freezing right so that we
can clone Skippy in a thousand years
oh that's my boy gate you know it did
get a prostitute man chickabee saw late
night he's religious whatever yeah look
at the church
hey Frank yeah come on kids yeah God
draw a line somewhere
come on all right then all right uh
let's go here we're gonna see yourselves
hello there's this nice a 1-second lay
here one second sis we there's one yeah
it's like half a second off me likey all
right hit me up big boys and this [ __ ]
quick they're all right we gotta finish
this Hennessey uh yeah definitely we
actually finished the bumpy let's do
this play it I love Newton in the news
what do you notice that I was trying to
[Music]
Olympic Jake is the best luck for this
[ __ ] long time what's the [ __ ]
durian for Christ's sake ended all right
what tell you got alright so welcome
welcome everyone to the news
so first up this one this one's for
Ethan really oh my god
sort of tangibly related to to his hero
here we had a vote in the house
representatives last week on Wednesday
about self-driving cars okay and kind of
surprisingly to me
they're completely for it and we have
now nationally legalized self-driving
cars I guess it was on a state-by-state
basis in some states that legalized it a
lot of them hadn't I think California is
one of the few that was down with it but
on a very limited basis and yeah and
Congress they have voted to cross the
board lessen the regulations which is
like a little scary so gay marriage gay
marriage we did a slippery slope trucks
yes start cars strike driving themselves
and next you know people are [ __ ]
animals and married next thing you know
one little statistic in here though that
I thought was interesting dance computer
is black it's black that's what Ian said
he might be [ __ ] with me though screen
black screen yeah alright let's read
rigor this nobody say anything just
quiet silence it's gonna work
dead air this is cold we re plugged it
in we got it
Ian talk to me tell me talk to me in
yeah still no still no that's what he
says this is all gonna be left in
oh and I don't know what's going on
we're gonna just describe what's on the
[Music]
[ __ ] you guys are the [ __ ] best
alright we have to make this like a
monthly occasion say the word word we'll
just follow Beauty by [ __ ] news
alright dude I think get on with it
alright do we start from scratch I mean
that was kind of blown from all right so
so we all live in LA right yes yeah so
it's been hot as [ __ ] the last couple
weeks here and it's terrible so the
mayor of Los Angeles is gonna do
something about it he's gonna dab on the
hate he's gonna dab all those Sun good
for him NASA is official diagnosis it's
a real thing Garcetti mayor Garcetti he
is sort of like a evil scientist I guess
he's whether manipulating LA's mayor
wants to lowers the city's temperature
apparently so they did this big study
turns out there's like all these simple
things that you can do to actually just
across the board lower the ambient
temperature of the city the biggest
thing is asphalt so asphalt huh black
asphalt absorbs a ton of energy
yeah and that heat is just kind of
locked in and it radiates off and when
you multiply that across the Los Angeles
area which is [ __ ] huge it actually
has a net effect like it's raising the
temperature by itself they own five to
ten degrees basically so they're gonna
repave the whole city with this new like
special coating that will bounce all the
light off and they asked me just that
alone will lower the temperature in the
city by three to five degrees [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah um and then there's other things
too so they can put maybe you guys have
seen this before they they've figured
out how to put grass on rules I love
that right and so same thing that having
grass up there instead
black shingles is going to absorbs the
heat a huge amount of heat planting more
trees so he is actually set a goal that
by what is it in the next 20 years he
wants to lower the average temperature
in the city of Los Angeles by 3 to 5
degrees so it's just that 100 100 we day
will be a 95 degree day that's a noble
effort yeah yeah a noble effort they ran
out for asphalt heat when they do
temperature readings on them yeah yeah
it's actually pretty interesting so yet
a traditional asphalt it absorbs 90% of
the sun's radiation which is like you
know 90% is a lot just to clarify I know
further percentile yeah I don't have AC
in my room so I definitely feel it but
Eric it makes your video so much better
I am a sweaty boy so this kind of
demonstrates it this is a picture of
some asphalt and in the background there
the the darker asphalt that is the
asphalt that we all know and love
yeah and this is the new stuff that they
want to put on right now you can see in
the infrared ray what a difference that
makes us this 138 degrees Fahrenheit
versus 96 versus 96 yeah
so yeah that's huge so they want to redo
the entire city which you know it's a
sprawling city I mean we have a couple
of highways in LA a few yeah yeah you do
yeah oh yeah
that's all good hobby hey it's like a
rush I'll [ __ ] bet it is weird yeah
I'll bet like once we get to the age
where we can't fry an egg on the asphalt
we'll have one yeah that's dope that's I
honestly though that is an ingenious
solution yeah to a problem that is
inevitable like let's let's face it it's
pretty this is 20 year plan I need to be
re-elected ten times that dude literally
dead dab on Jake Paul so hard and his
own guys got a good track right yeah you
took it to the top there with that one
all right so okay okay alright so next
story moving on
I got a couple a couple stories from
Japan so for all you we we booze we have
Italian thank you
I'm more vote should be very excited
guys in Wow
[ __ ] hard that was that me white
ghost actually don't know guys you
whatever white ghost means and you're
the [ __ ] weeaboo right now
so you guys have you ever heard of
CRISPR I think yes it's so this is
pretty interesting stuff so CRISPR is
this what is it it's derived from a
bacteria a certain type of bacteria and
basically scientists have figured out a
way to utilize it to in a very targeted
way edit DNA mmm
and you know this is still in
development they haven't really
perfected or anything but they're
getting closer and closer and the
implications of that as you can imagine
are pretty crazy
alright so scientists in Japan have just
recently successfully been able to on a
consultive lee consistent basis they
said 75 percent success rate for all you
percentage buffs out there
h we know there there are many a lot
there a lot with seventy five percent
accuracy are able to change this
particular type of Morning Glory flower
from white to purple huh and so they can
just you had me at Morning Glory so what
you're saying is in terms of Twin Peaks
it is possible to have a coke it's a
blue rose coke
yes exactly right yes in choice and be
able to use it in the show on a
consistent basis and may 75% of the
shops were like mutants you can modify
the genetics of a little baby yep a
little a little sapling will seed a
human being is you know so just like
dollar the cheap kind of [ __ ] or like
they're all not dollar but I mean like
they're trying okay so this is like baby
steps
Jing so a couple is pregnant and they
you know have the DNA tested of the
embryo when they find out it's gonna
have water brown eyes yeah and they're
like something a lot more not your brown
eyes right right well that so that's
where I need an unethical thing like you
know oh I want my baby designer babies
basically baby
with all the options that's like the
morally gray area but the foot side of
that is you know you could have you know
you could have a baby that has some sort
of genetic disorder that you know is
gonna cause a horrible life or horrible
pain and go in there and literally
splice out that little piece of DNA
that's incorrect and she correct it now
you have a whole life ahead of you of
not having some kind of having a few you
know giant cause you're now let's say I
wanted a lobster hand baby yep CRISPR
can make your dreams in the future and
my youtube channel is going to be daddy
Oh lobster daddy oh no claw daddy oh two
o'clock I'm gonna throw them into a
[ __ ] dresser quite reminds me of one
punch man all my [ __ ] pimps out there
what do you got there quick a quick
update a breaking news bulletin Oh
gaijin means foreigner apparently in a
derogatory sense of the stupid Warner
guys don't that gringo ass in all of my
negligence was correct yes that's right
which fed into the negligence in the
first place beautiful what else we got
all right so I also coming to you from
Japan so recently out in in the old
Japan here
they had this outbreak of this disease
that spread by ticks right and it's a
what is it called has like a really
crazy name here the
the abbreviation is SFTs okay so as SFTs
na is this kind of uh looks like a fever
it's kind of like hay fever
yeah something it has about a 30% death
rate if you catch up that's pretty yeah
by the way it's been four and a half
hours there has been drinking the whole
time go to the bar with these guys it's
four and a half hours yeah wait thirty
percent death rate that's terrifying
well up to thirty it gives you low
platelet count fever vomiting diarrhea
six out of this country
not a damn wall well yeah we're talking
keep them out so lock that thing up so
check it out in in the Miyazaki
Prefecture
I think it's Prefecture it's like
they're States Baker I really
underestimated that guy's feeling there
Smith or something yeah I'm from Kevin
Smith Alabama so the officials in
Miyazaki held a news conference to you
know warn everybody that this is a
problem be on the lookout and they
brought two tix to show to the audience
one dead and one alive
and so they only went through this whole
press conference talking about you know
this is this is a serious thing and you
know this is a deadly disease and it can
affect anybody and you know this is a
big problem after they get done
explaining to the room all of that they
use a pair of tweezers and pick up the
tick and drop it oh [ __ ] no and that
thing was loaded with life oh yeah Ebola
bats and everything did they clear my
god well apparently everybody did
freaked out but then every like all of
the reporters everybody like jumped into
action and they're like crawling around
and like everybody has like you know I
used to the floor like with because it's
like a tickets like nightmares
microscopic right tiny all right losing
a contact lens yes way where yeah we the
the consequences are yeah amplified yes
reach much farther sorry
so they failed and eventually cleared
out the room and just mass disinfected
it just blasted the entire building that
somebody went home what's a tick in
their ass and the country of Japan is
[ __ ] and that's how a new animation
attack on tick boom I'm seriously good I
gotta end this
are you done I'm done he's checked out
yeah we're dumb baby
a couple okay we can yeah no I mean even
after the charity stream what do we know
I'm [ __ ] yourself I'm sober as [ __ ] I
can talk about isn't this what a podcast
is yeah on the charity well let's check
it out okay great question
this is a quick thirty four two three
four
yeah we started like 232 I know guys
you're bragging do not want me to smoke
show my [ __ ] [ __ ] the talk about
the fact that this is in a jar of like
amphetamine pills is it I never looked
at the actual stay awake during the
meeting pills it's literally called sang
stay awake during the meeting all right
I stayed awake during the meeting five
our podcast [ __ ] Wow USA you laugh
alright guys as I said thank you to my
Fupa troopers
thank you to my dogs Eric and Jack hey I
think that channels are in the
description
dan you did okay today I wanna give you
a chance
Sarah I love you all you guys are
killing it
Tuesday we don't have a show
Tuesday we are [ __ ] basically me and Dan
are we moved to new house or setting up
the new studio we move to a new house me
and heal Dan is incidentally helping me
I am so trashed all right what'd you say
would you say Dan is caring for you in a
sort thank you came over yesterday
helped me took with the garbage out
don't worry guys we're gonna go over to
Ethan's we're gonna cook them in nice
little possible okay I'm sure our salmon
have a perfect way to do crispy skin
salmon I love that crispy skin just like
I like my children
crispy gangbanged gonna soar in Stuart
and I like I guess that I like my kids
anyway guys thanks for watching hope you
had as much fun as we did
we'll see you next Friday there's no
podcast on Tuesday thank you to our
guests we love you Super Trouper nation
keep it strong keep it hot keep it spicy
this your boy signing out
cut it
[Music]